Hi Kilian! Hi Hendrik! Willkommen bei Akronymisierbar Folge 59.
Wir haben es geschafft! Endlich nach 59 Folgen haben wir es geschafft,
alle unsere Aufzeichnungen und Transkripte in ein LLM zu füttern und können
euch jetzt die erste automatisch generierte Akronymisierbar-Folge präsentieren.
Dazu haben wir einfach unsere Shownotes in ein LLM geschoben und es hat uns
nach viel Rechnen diese Folge generiert. Und das Beste daran,
wir müssen nicht mal die Folge selber skripten, sondern es kommt alles direkt aus den Shownotes.
Super praktisch. Wir können euch das nur empfehlen.
Also viel Spaß mit der ersten Folge automatisierbar, vollständig AI generiert.
Music.
Das ist so doof.
Das krasse ist ja, diese Notebook LLM-Podcasts, die sind ja so richtig,
also du hörst einfach so 80% der US-Based-Podcasts in der Art und Weise, wie die sprechen.
Ich finde, die klingen so ein bisschen wie so eine Quarks-Folge,
Quarks Daily gibt es auch noch, die ist auch so ein bisschen so ähnlich.
Das habe ich gar nicht im Kopf, aber ja, wahrscheinlich.
Also das ist ja, ich meine, die sind ja sicherlich trainiert auf Unmengen an Podcasts.
Ja, und bei uns sind die auch auf fast, wie lange ist unsere Sendezeit insgesamt?
Stimmt, stimmt. Wir haben einen Meister und erreichen wir mit dieser Folge vorausgesetzt.
Wir schaffen sie lang genug, was wahrscheinlich der Fall sein wird.
Ich glaube, 51 Minuten müssen wir schaffen oder so. Dann sind wir bei insgesamt 100 Stunden Content.
Also mit den 99 Stunden, die wir bereits haben, konnten wir es relativ gut schaffen,
diese Folge zu synthetisieren.
Ihr müsst ein bisschen darauf achten, dass sich Kilians Lachen wahrscheinlich
immer wieder gleich anhört.
Ich muss ihn einfach ins Soundboard mit aufnehmen. Der kommt jetzt an dieser Stelle.
Ja. Ich würde sich könnte auf Anhieb so ein Wilhelm screamen. Das wäre cool.
Genau. Nee, aber wir haben jetzt schon eine Weile nicht mehr gemacht.
Es ist viel passiert im letzten Jahr. Was ist denn alles passiert?
10. April 24. Das ist über ein Jahr her.
Wir sollten das nicht zu groß an die hohe Glocke... Weißt du,
was wir machen? Wir machen das wie Apple. Wir ändern unser Nummerierungsschema
und das hier ist Folge 25.
26, das ist die Folge bis nächste einfach jetzt.
Wir nennen die Folge einfach Folge 26.
Das finde ich auch wunderbar. Wir sehen mal 59, Folge 26.
Aber nächstes Jahr machen wir Folge 27. Das ist ehrlich, ich bin gelaufen.
Was ist denn alles passiert im letzten Jahr? Wie gesagt, ich finde,
wir sollten das nicht so an die große Glocke hängen, weil es ist wie wenn man
einen Blog schreibt, wo man immer wieder bloß schreibt, wie man sich ein neues
Blogging sieht. Warte, das habe ich sogar gefunden.
Genau das gab es. Das habe ich ein paar Jahre lang gemacht. Das habe ich natürlich
komplett vergessen. Das habe ich in unseren.
Linkdump reingeschmissen. Das ist nämlich genau das. Da hat jemand ein Diagramm gezeichnet.
Number of Blogposts versus Number of Posts about elaborate Blogsetups.
Und du hast halt Blogs mit sehr vielen Posts, sind halt so WordPress-Blogs von
2004 oder so eine alte Blogger.com-Seite oder so ein cooler MIT-Professor.
Mein alter Blog war die erste Ausgabe, mein erster Eintrag war,
wie ich meinen BBPHP aufgesetzt habe.
Und der zweite war, wie ich dann von BBPHP auf WordPress umgezogen bin.
Du hast ein Forum benutzt.
Ach nee, das war PHPBB.
PHPBB, nee, oder irgendwas anderes. Post, weil es ist es ist,
lass es 20 Jahre her sein.
Die Technik ist vielleicht schon gestorben. Aber auf der anderen Seite von dieser
Skala sind dann halt so Org Mode Fans, Move from Jekyll to Hugo People,
oder Authors of Custom Static Side Channel.
Und ich weiß auch, ich habe also bestimmt mehr als die Hälfte.
All die Static Site Generators gefallen mir nicht, ich muss mir erstmal meinen eigenen machen.
Absolut fair. Das ist ja aber, das ist der Inbegriff von Prokrastination, oder?
Ja, und locker die Hälfte der Poster auf meinem Blog waren wirklich Blogumzug.
Wir haben ja auch relativ lange
darüber nachgedacht, uns unsere eigene Podcasting-Hosting-Application
zu bauen. Ich kann nur an die.
Mikrowelle Ja, ja, doch, Mikrowelle. Mikrowelle OS, genau. Die das sehr erfolgreich
gemacht haben, konnten wir allerdings nichts von benutzen, war leider alles
in Go geschrieben. War es in Go? Ja, ja.
Das weiß ich schon gar nicht mehr. Ich weiß bloß, dass ich versucht habe,
das zu nutzen und bin gegen ein paar kleine Customizability-Wände gerannt,
weil ich Dinge anders machen wollte.
Und dann war es halt ein Nee, lass mal doch selber.
Aber jetzt hast du ja zumindest unser Frontend komplett handgestrickt.
Ja, aber das ist ja schon Ewigkeiten her. Das ist ja schon fünf Folgen und das
ist zehn Jahre gefühlt her.
Genau, vielleicht sollten wir irgendwann mal so eine kleine Behind-the-Scenes-Sonderfolge
machen. Ich bin auch tatsächlich immer noch ganz stolz darauf.
Also es ist sehr simpel, es ist sehr kostenlos und es ist sehr stabil.
Schreibt uns mal in die Kommentare.
Es sind auf unserer Webseite zu finden, akkognizier.bar.
Wenn ihr eine Behind-the-Scenes Sonderfolge von Kilian haben wollt,
wie die akkognizierbare Podcasting-Infrastruktur.
Behind-the-Scenes-Folge, das wäre mal die nächste Folge.
Wir haben nicht mal die Infra für eine separate, non-lineare Feed-Folge. Vielleicht.
Ja, was ist sonst alles bei dir passiert in der letzten Zeit?
Also, es ist ein Jahr, es ist eine lange Zeit, da ist vieles passiert.
Ich habe bestimmt fünfmal meinen Browser gewechselt und 20mal mein Betriebssystem.
Also, ich habe seit 20 Jahren meinen Browser nicht gewechselt.
Wie viele Browser gibt es denn neben Firefox?
Ich war lange doch so ein Arc-Fanboy und habe das Ding benutzt,
bis die den mittlerweile auch schon wieder eingestammt haben.
Das war auch so eine Rugpull-Geschichte, oder?
Nein, nein, nein, ganz im Gegenteil, das will ich jetzt auch nicht sagen,
aber es war definitiv kein Rugpull.
Die haben halt versucht, eine Firma aufzuziehen und dabei einen neuen Browser zu bauen.
Festgestellt, dass man mit dem Browser selber kein Geld verdienen kann.
Ja, und die haben halt in Anführungsstrichen Visionen, für was die Zukunft des Browsen sein sollte.
Und das geht halt ein bisschen mehr Richtung Agentic Browsing,
also dass da mehr AI drin sein soll. Ein Thema, das ich jetzt nicht weiter ausführen möchte hier.
Aber es ist ein bisschen weird, was sie sich da alles vorstellen,
was sie machen wollen. Aber sie haben auf dem Weg dahin halt einen technisch
eigentlich ganz coolen Browser gebaut, nämlich komplett in Swift.
Also was heißt komplett in Swift? Sie haben den Browser gebaut,
aber nicht die Engine darunter.
Und das ist halt ein Chromium gewesen, was sie da reingebundelt haben.
Aber das Drumherum war halt eine Swift-Anwendung. Es war eine sehr schicke Anwendung
mit sehr viel schöner UX, die mir sehr gefallen hat, die genau das war,
was ich eigentlich haben wollte, nämlich vertikale Tabbar.
Furchtbar. Das kann man bei Firefox mittlerweile anmachen. Nicht furchtbar.
Nein, furchtbar. Das ist Platzverschwendung. Was?
Ja, das sieht furchtbar aus. Wie Platzverschwendung. Ich kann meine Tabs lesen
und habe den Platz für die Webseite.
Anyway, red weiter. Ich habe es zweimal ausprobiert. Ich finde,
das sieht ganz furchtbar aus. Also ich kann nicht mehr ohne.
Jedenfalls haben die noch ein paar andere Sachen gemacht und die hatten so ein
cooles Feature, dass wenn du ein neues Fenster öffnest, wenn du den Link irgendwo
anklickst, dann geht ein kleines, separates Fenster auf, was losgelöst aus dem Browser-Kontext ist.
Und was richtig schicker finde ich, wenn du da drin irgendwas gemacht hast,
sei es beispielsweise vielleicht am eindrucksvollsten, du hast ein YouTube-Video
angeschaut und es läuft zur Hälfte schon und du hast auf den Button gedrückt,
der dieses Fenster in den normalen Browser mit integriert hat,
ein Fenster, dann hat das nicht das geschlossen und drüben neu geladen,
sondern es hat quasi einfach nur das Tab durchgeschoben in das andere rein und
hat aber diesen Kontext komplett offengelassen, also den Viewport komplett offengelassen
dazu und gar nicht berührt im
Ladekontext, ich weiß gar nicht, wie ich das gut beschreiben kann,
aber das halt im Steam, das weiter lief, es wurde gar nichts geändert an der
Playback-Session oder was auch immer du gerade in dem Tab gemacht hast,
Textfelder befüllt, was auch wir.
Es ging so ein Modal auf, wo das dann drin war. Genau, quasi.
Es ist wie, wenn ich in so einer iOS-App auf den Link klicke und das in so einem
Embedded-Browser aufgeht. So ein bisschen so.
Plus, dass es halt separate Fenster war und du konntest dann auch beliebig viele von offen haben.
Aber du hattest auch tatsächlich noch so einen extra Modal-Mode,
der ist auch sehr geil gewesen. Weil ich habe zum Beispiel immer mal Hacker-News.
Unsere lieblingsrussische Front-Ein-Seite für Y-Combinator. Die nutze ich,
oder betrugend lese ich jeden Tag in der Früh. Ich habe immer noch keinen Dark-Mode.
Ja, ich habe auch schon einen Dark-Mode. Ich bin Light-Mode-Fanboy.
Bzw. ich bin Automatic-Switching-Fanboy. Ich tagsüber... Geht ja nicht.
Ja, aber da schaue ich immer nur tagsüber drauf.
Also ich mache die nachts manchmal auf und dann bin ich nochmal wach.
Nee, da schaue ich da irgendwo drauf. Aber wenn ich die halt gepinnt habe und
da links anklicke, dann öffnen die sich direkt zum Modell.
Das waren auf jeden Fall haufenweise so kleine UX-Nicities, die ich für den
Browser echt schön und klug fand.
Gut durchdacht und mal so gefühlt so ein bisschen was Neueres.
Und warum benutzt du es jetzt nicht?
Weil die den nicht mehr weiterentwickeln wollen. Die haben beschlossen,
damit verdienen sie kein Geld und das ist das, was sie machen wollen.
Das ist erstmal eine Plattform oder irgendwie eine Library.
Ja, nee, sie haben das Ding quasi eingestampft und machen jetzt ein Ding namens
Dia, was ein bisschen mehr in deren Visionen geht.
Aber ist da leider hingestellt, denn es gibt noch was, was, finde ich,
noch ein bisschen cooler ist. Nämlich gibt es Leute, die haben sich gedacht,
Mensch, die UX von Arc ist geil.
Lass das mal kopieren, aber in Open Source und auf Firefox-Basis. Und das ist Zen.
Und Zen ist einfach so ein geiler Browser. Also ich kann ihn pink machen,
so wie ich Arc hatte. Ich habe genau diese vertikale Tabbar.
Ich habe auch die Möglichkeiten, nicht auch die vertikale Tabbar zu nutzen.
Das habe ich nicht geschafft, wie ich das ausmachen würde. Ich habe ganz kurz mal Zen verwendet.
Festgestellt, wenn man in die Toolbar klickt, dann ist es eigentlich Firefox,
weil die Customized-Toolbar-Dialoge sehen genauso aus wie bei Firefox.
Das ist einfach bloß das Frontend obendrauf anders.
Ich sehe gar keine Möglichkeit für das. Vielleicht gibt es das nicht mehr oder
ich habe es noch versteckt. Keine Ahnung. Weiß ich nicht. Interessiert mich nicht.
Aber es ist quasi genau das, was ich in Arc hatte.
Und mittlerweile haben sie auch featuremäßig und die Stability stark nachgezogen,
also jetzt ist es das, was ich in Arc hatte, auf Firefox drauf,
was sich noch besser anfühlt, jetzt wo Google auch sowas wie,
also was haben wir mit diesem neue Manifest Extension API, das die U-Block komplett
kaputt gemacht haben, U-Block Origin,
dadurch muss man nicht mehr auf Chromium-Basis jetzt sein, ist mit Firefox umso
happier, das finde ich toll.
Jetzt müsste nur wieder mehr Energie und Liebe in die Firefox-Entwicklung fließen,
damit die Browser-Engine nicht mehr Jahre hinter Chromium hinterher lenkt.
Versuche einfach nicht darüber nachzudenken.
Ich erwische mich dabei, wie ich zum Entwickeln manchmal dann doch wieder Chromium
aufmache, weil die DevTools in Firefox einige Bugs haben. Aber dazu gibt es ein sehr schönes Theo.
Das mir sehr das Herz gebrochen hat. Aber er hat damit recht,
Firefox ist in einigen Stellen leider so ein bisschen überholt.
Ich kann den nur manchmal anschauen. Der ist mir ein bisschen zu...
Anyway, das waren jetzt Browser. Das waren Browser. Okay, gut.
Was ist das Jahr, wie man so passiert war? Die eigentliche Frage.
Keine Ahnung. Hast du irgendwelche großen Sachen, die passiert sind?
Bei mir ist so einiges, wir hatten ein, zweimal über die, achso,
ja, ich habe dafür ein Lookup-Tool gebaut.
Ah, stimmt. Schreibt er sich so?
Jeff. Jeff Bezos. Genau. Du hast hier gerade einen Tab aufgemacht.
Also das Einzige, was ich weiß, ist, dass ich dir kürzlich alle unsere Folgen
transkribiert habe, zu Text. Also, Moment, nicht spoilern.
Was ich eigentlich erzählen wollte, ist, wir hatten in Folge 53 einmal über
das Schiff des Bezos geredet.
Und da habe ich erwähnt, dass ich relativ lange einen Fork, eines Actor-Frameworks entwickelt habe.
Der hieß Hannibal. Und das Hauptproblem war, dass ich mir über die Lizenz von
dem Ding nicht im Klaren war, weil ich es ja geforkt habe.
Und ich fand das eh schon nicht so nice, irgendwie andere Leute zu forken und
dann als seins zu verkaufen.
Das macht man nicht. Das machen die Leute ständig.
Aber irgendwie hat er... In der MIT-Lizenz, ich glaube, was ich damals schon
gesagt habe, in der MIT-Lizenz steht oben irgendwie Copyright Mozilla drin.
Und da habe ich mir gedacht, das stimmt bei dem Originaldings,
was ich geforkt habe, schon nicht.
Das hatte der sich wahrscheinlich ursprünglich irgendeine MIT-License-Datei woanders kopiert.
Das wurde mir dann alles zu heiß und aus Interesse hatte ich irgendwie gedacht,
ach, ich probiere das Ding mal ohne hinzugucken, obwohl ich den Fork maintained
habe, wirklich ohne unter die
Haut zu gucken, mal von vorne nochmal so ein Framework zu schreiben. Geil.
Und das hat mich dann in ein paar Wochen eigentlich über das letzte Jahr relativ
busy gehalten. Und es war ein schönes Bastel-Hobby-Nebenbei-Projekt.
Und dann habe ich irgendwann, es gab bereits das Repo Honeyball in meinem GitHub-Space
und das gepublishede Crate Honeyball.
Und dann habe ich das Repo irgendwann umbenannt in Honeyball Old und habe dann
das neue Repo Honeyball genannt und eine Version übersprungen und wieder auf Crate.io gepublished.
Und damit ist quasi Version 10 war der Fork, Version 0.10 war der Fork und Version
0.12 ist ein Complete Rewrite. Warum hast du die 11 übersprungen?
Für die Distinction. So wie man von Winamp 3 zu 5 gegangen ist. Oder PHP 5 zu 7.
Genau, oder da gibt es ja, oder von iOS... 18 zu 26.
Genau. Das war so ein Projekt.
Und ich muss sagen, es hat Spaß gemacht. Ich habe auch auf dem neuen Repo jetzt
schon drei Sterne. Geil. Es ist viral.
Es hebt richtig ab. Und es hat Spaß gemacht. Ich habe auf Arbeit ein paar Mal Projekte gewechselt.
Momentan habe ich das unglaubliche Privileg, auf Arbeit ein bisschen Rust machen zu dürfen.
Eine Lüge, du hast schon vier Sterne in dem Repo. Wie ist denn das passiert?
Ich habe heute erst den ganzen Tag Windows APIs in Rust mit einem Kollegen zusammen durchpflügt.
Warum?
Für Arbeitsprojekte würdest du das persönlich nicht machen? Furchtbar,
ganz furchtbar. Kannst du dazu irgendwas an Kontext erzählen?
Also wir bauen eine Anwendung für, meine Firma verkauft Software für Windows.
Und die hat Untermodule und Untermodule werden auch unterschiedliche Teams entwickelt.
Und mein Team hat sich entschieden, unser Untermodul wollen wir nicht in C++
bauen, das machen wir jetzt in Rust.
Und du musst allerdings trotzdem irgendwelche Windows-APIs einsprechen,
zum Beispiel, um mit Maus und Keyboard-Input zu interagieren oder den Bildschirm abzuscannen.
Und ich sage dir, diese APIs sind zum Kotzen. Furchtbar.
Ganz furchtbar. Ich hätte ja zwischendurch mal so eine Marke drücken können.
Also ich habe literally noch nie Windows-System-APIs interagiert.
Es gibt ja diese wunderschöne Windows-Crate und im Endeffekt denkst du,
also du denkst, du darfst Rust schreiben, aber du musst trotzdem Windows-API-Funktionen
benutzen und du darfst dann trotzdem obskure Pointertypen hin- und hercasten in Unsafe,
und es gibt Funktionen, da gibst du einen Struck zum Schreiben rein,
was du vorher leer initialisierst, was jetzt so C++, C-mäßig gar nicht so untypisch ist oder C-typisch.
Bei Windows hast du die Sondereigenschaften, dass das Struct,
was du reingibst, hinterher nicht unbedingt dieselbe Größe haben muss,
wie du es vorher alloziert hast.
Was natürlich mit Rust überhaupt nicht kompatibel ist.
Das heißt, du hast dann selbst dort mehrere Situationen, wo du einen beliebig,
allozierten großen Speicher reingibst, den Pointer dazu irgendwo reingibst und dann zurückkriegst.
Ich hab da jetzt übrigens so und so viele Bytes reingeschrieben und das darfst
du dann, und da hab ich viele Sachen über Memory Management in Rust gelernt,
erst heute. Zum Beispiel.
StoodMemNonOverlappingCopy. Herrlich. Ich habe hier einen N großen Speicher
und hier ein N großes Struct, kopier doch mal die Daten in dieses Struct rein,
bis zu der Größe von beliebig und den Rest kannst du abschneiden. So ein Scheiß.
Und mit dem Rest lass ich euch jetzt auch in Ruhe, weil wir ja ein anderes Thema
angefangen hatten. Ja, aber das ist doch...
Im Endeffekt geht es darum, eine Anwendung zu enablen, ich möchte jetzt nicht
zu viel noch über die Details erzählen,
aber eine Anwendung, die momentan noch von Menschen bedient werden muss,
zu enablen, von AI-Agenten bedient werden zu können.
Und damit schließe ich den Bogen zu diesem Agentic in the Browser-Thema,
was du gerade angesprochen hast, mit dem Zen-Browser.
Nee, ARC. Zen ist cool. ARC. Zen ist nix AI. mit dem Arc-Browser,
weil offenbar momentan so ein Trend ist, dass in jeder Anwendung noch ein Agent
eingebaut wird oder ein Agentic-Mode eingebaut.
Naja, also jetzt sind wir erstmal über das, überall muss AI reingequetscht werden,
rübergegangen zu, hey, Agentic-AI ist ja noch viel cooler, die macht ja was
für dich und nicht so die gibt dir mehr Datenmüll.
Also vor zwei Jahren hat jeder überall einfach so einen kleinen Co-Pilot eingebaut,
mit dem du ein bisschen schnacken konntest und der hat dir dann irgendwie ein
peinliches Gedicht über deine Firma erzeugt, wo deine eigene Firma gedisst hat.
Und dann haben sich die Software-Teams erstmal damit beschäftigt,
den ganzen Chatbots beizubringen per Prompt Engineering, dass sie bitte nicht
scheiße über die Firma reden sollen.
Und mittlerweile sind Agents überall drin. In VS Code sind Agents drin.
Dann gibt es Firmen, die gründen sich, weil sie noch mehr Geld riechen und forken
VS Code, um einen schöneren Agent dort einzubauen.
Ja, aber ein bisschen böse. In Browsern sind Agents drin. Firefox hat so einen Firefox hat einen.
Ich hab's ausgemacht, aber Firefox hat auch ein AI Chatbot Feature.
Das ist einfach ein eingebautes LLM. Und dann hat man hier ein Da kann man ein
Claw Chat GPT oder Hacking Face Chat oder Lit Chat Mistral Tab.
Also es gibt einfach einen extra Browser Sidebar, wo ein Tab offen ist zu den Chatbots.
Ich hab's noch nicht ausprobiert, Ich gehe davon aus, dass dieser Tab zu einem
gewissen Grad Zugriff auf deinen Browser-Kontext hat, um irgendwie für dich
da so ein bisschen mitzulesen, was prinzipiell jetzt nicht doof ist,
aber ich mach's mal lieber schnell wieder aus.
Da ist der Button gewesen für Turn on vertical tabs, click it.
Come to the dark side. Guck mal hier, das passt doch alles da oben hin.
Guck mal, wie fett dieses Ding ist. Du hast einen Tab offen.
Mach mal 10 auf und sag das nochmal.
Dann siehst du nämlich nur noch Favikon. Wenn ich bei meinen Kollegen meistens
auf manche Systeme schaue... Jetzt zeig ich dir noch ein UI-Feature,
was noch älter ist als Tabs?
Fenster. Nein, ein Browserfenster. Ich will ein Browserfenster, maximal zwei.
Weißt du, was ich noch manchmal mache? Ich mache Tabs wieder zu. Na.
Ich muss ja von den Teufel austreiben hier. Baut ihr denn schon,
oder hast du denn schon irgendwo Agents eingebaut?
Naja, also ich meine, auf Arbeit hatten wir auch so eine Art,
Hilfsbot-Ding da, was dir helfen sollte, was...
Es ist Schrott. Okay, ich bring dich jetzt nicht in die Priduie,
dass du irgendwie schlecht über deine Arbeit krimieren sollst.
Das geht auch in eine andere Richtung weiter.
Ich bin ja in meiner Rolle als Kailian...
Das wusste ich gar nicht. Es gibt ja tatsächlich auch, ich nutze ja recht viele
Tools in der Hinsicht, aber ich glaube, das KI-Thema würde sich sogar lohnen,
wenn wir uns das mehr oder weniger aufsparen für die nächste Folge.
Ich glaube, wir können ja auch ankündigen, es gibt bald eine neue.
Was? Das kriegt ihr mit. Nicht erst nächstes Jahr. Nicht erst nächstes Jahr.
Steht mal wieder mit dem Naming.
Nee, also aber da können wir ein bisschen mehr darüber reden.
Das passt dann auch ein bisschen thematisch besser.
Und dann lassen wir das heute mal ein bisschen aus dem Vor-IS-Seilen kommen.
Ich kann dir nur kurz dämon, dass ich eine kleine Spielzeuganwendung gebaut
habe. Genau, darauf Wollte ich jetzt endlich mal zurückkommen.
Ich habe vorhin bloß irgendwas gesagt dazu, dass ich dir Podcast-Transkripte von uns alle.
Genau, wir haben in mühevoller Kleinarbeit alle unsere Folgen händisch abgeschrieben.
Weißt du, wie lange das gedauert hätte für 99 Stunden? So viel Scheißarbeit.
Zumindest habe ich von Kilian irgendwie vor ein paar Tagen einen wunderschönen
Zip-Ordner gekriegt, mit allen akronomisierbar Folgen in unterschiedlichen Formaten Text.
Also ich habe Kontext, die alle einfach durch ein USB-Model durchgeschoben.
Und es hat zu 90 Prozent gut geklappt. Natürlich sind einzelne Sachen halt nicht
ganz sauber, aber damit kann man jetzt schon was anfangen. Und zwar?
Und zwar habe ich damit, und das ist auch ich muss zugeben, gevibecodet,
diese Anwendung gebaut, die alle unsere Transkripts nimmt.
Also was wollte ich machen? Ich wollte in der Lage sein, während einer Folge
sagen zu können, wie wir bereits in Folge 53 erwähnt haben,
weil ich immer super eifersüchtig auf Florian Freistetter bin,
der 600 Folgen Podcast macht und in jeder Folge,
mindestens einmal sagt, wie ich bereits in Folge 126 gesagt habe, was 10 Jahre her ist.
Das ist impressive. Da gefühlt hat der das aber auch im Kopf.
Du kannst gar nicht grundsätzlich davon ausgehen, dass die Podcast-Apps der
Leute soweit zurückscrollen können, aber der hat tatsächlich ein Feed,
wo alle 600 Folgen Sehr schön, nicht so ein krank beschnittene Feed,
wie manche andere Podcast-Zeitverbrechen.
Den kenne ich nicht. Zumindest gibt es natürlich so Anwendungen,
ich wollte nur eine kleine Rack-Anwendung bauen.
Und das heißt, du nimmst deine... Für den Kontext, was ist ein Rack? Ein Rack ist eine...
Rack steht für Retrieval Augmented Generation. Ein Begriff, lass uns jetzt hier
keine AI-Vorlesung draus machen. Die Leute schalten nur ab.
Was ich bauen wollte, war eine kleine AI-Suchanwendung, wo ich unsere ganzen
Transcripts reinschieben kann, wo ich dann ein Interface habe,
was mir Fragen zu unserer Sendung beantwortet mit einem kleinen lokalen LNM.
Das habe ich natürlich gewebe-coded. Und was man dazu nimmt,
also was ich hier genommen habe, ist ChromaDB, was so eine Vektordatenbank ist.
Das kann man glücklicherweise fast alles in Python machen.
Da fütterst du deine Daten, deine Transcripts rein. Dauert übrigens auch 15 Minuten.
Ich wollte krass sagen, was heißt die Vektor-Datenbank an der Stelle?
Also du hast wirklich die Transkripte verarbeitet und da reingespeichert,
damit die durchsuchbar sind. Quasi.
Mein Take-away ist, bei den Transcripts, wenn ich nach einem Thema suche,
ist es eigentlich fast einfacher, wenn ich eine Volltext suche.
Wir haben ja auch nicht Gigabytes an Textdaten, sondern das sind ja...
Aber was ich gerne gehabt hätte ist, sag mir doch mal Folgen,
wo wir so grob über dieses Thema geredet haben oder was haben wir denn schon
zu diesem Thema gesagt und dann so inhaltlich zusammenfassen.
Und das hat einigermaßen geklappt. Ich glaube, was ich jetzt hier habe,
ist so eine kleine Maske.
Gebaut ist das Frontend mit Streamlit, was irgendwie von den Daten-Science-Leuten
bei mir auf Arbeit relativ viele Leute verwenden.
Das war so ein Python-Framework für... Das war so ein Python-Framework,
wo du einfach im Server dein Frontend grob in Python-Befehlen zusammenstrickst
und das baut dir dann so eine live-re-rendernde Web-Frontend-Geschichte da zusammen.
Dann habe ich hier einen Button, wo ich einmal alle Transcripts nochmal von
vorne laden kann. Das würde nochmal 15 Minuten dauern.
Und dann habe ich eine Suchmaske und dann gibt er mir Antworten zu einem Thema,
eigentlich kann ich ja mal eben hier was anderes eingeben, Datenspuren. Aha, geil.
Sind du übrigens auch bald wieder? Und dann siehst du, dass er hier lädt und
ein bisschen rödelt und das...
Ich glaube, das Bottleneck ist, dass ich das auf einem O-Lama auf meinem Rechner
lokal mache, was natürlich kein sonderlich, also ich habe dann Lama 3.2 Latest
Modell genommen, keine Ahnung, das lässt sich alles noch optimieren.
Sagen wir so, ich habe hier eine Stunde dran gearbeitet, oder das ist zwei.
Und dann sagt er mir, weil ich ihm natürlich bloß Datenspuren gesagt habe und
ihm keine Antwort, keine Frage gestellt habe, die mir irgendwie ein Crew darauf
gibt, dass ich eigentlich Deutsch mit ihm sprechen möchte. Based on the provided
transcript experts, here is a breakdown of the term Datenspuren.
Ich finde es super, dass hier steht, the speaker confirms the existence of Datenspuren,
in Klammern, data trails multiple times.
Hier unten der Speaker steht, es sind wieder Datenspuren. There are again data trails.
Es gibt bestimmt, also falls ihr da draußen Beispiele kennt für,
hey, hier, pipet mal dieses gesamte Werk Podcasts hier rein und beantworte mal
kontextuelle, schlaue Fragen dazu.
Besser optimiert, dann schickt mir doch mal bitte Referenzen.
Was ich kenne tatsächlich sind von ATP, vom Exidental Tech Podcast,
da gibt es mindestens zwei,
Volltext-Suche-Tools, aber das ist halt kein LM dahinter, was jetzt also wie
gesagt, das ist ein Unterschied zwischen absolut korrekt und zwischen,
man will dazu Fragen stellen, die halt nicht genau in der Volltext-Suche aufwendbar sind.
Aber ich finde es trotzdem, also auch vom Interface ja ganz cool,
dass man da mal reinschauen kann, wie die ausschauen und wie die funktionieren.
Ist zumindest ein Use Case, den ich für LLMs tatsächlich als sehr praktisch
empfinde, einfach eine noch höher, leveligere Volltext zu machen.
Ja, nicht alles lässt sich immer mit einem Suchbegriff erschlagen.
Das ist absolut richtig. Vor allem, wenn du nicht weißt, nach was du suchst.
Genau, und das Nette ist, dass er mir hier also hier dazu auch noch die Chunks
zeigt, in denen diese Begriffe vorkommen, und dann quasi auf die Sources,
wo das ursprünglich herkommt, verweist.
Und hier sind quasi die Folgen 27, 33, 27, 33, 4, also es sind unterschiedlich zweimal die.
Die gleichen Folgen, unterschiedliche Segmente in den selben Sourcen. Genau.
Und der zeigt mir dann, was die Stelle ist in dem Bereich, wo das so kommt.
Ein bisschen schwierig wird natürlich auch dadurch, dass ein paar Transcription-Fehler
in den Transkripten mit drin sind.
Da hilft den LLM halt potenziell nochmal mehr oder halt auch nicht.
Komm ein bisschen drauf an. Also das Whisper ist ja auch in der Lage,
Podcasts zu transcriben und dann schreibt es Speaker 1 und Speaker 2 an die
Transcripts ran, ist natürlich nicht garantiert, dass das in jeder Folge Speaker
1 Kilian und Speaker 2 Hendrik ist.
Aber man könnte natürlich pro Folge mal kurz reinhören und schauen,
aber manchmal sind halt Speaker 3, wenn wir bloß zu zweit fahren,
manchmal sind halt noch mehr Leute dabei gewesen.
Man könnte mal Search and Replays pro Folge machen, das ist halt auch ein Haufen
Arbeit bei 58 Folgen. Aber...
Beziehungsweise 60 sind ja noch die Null mit dabei. Aber ja,
man könnte mal das ein bisschen aufbauen und annotieren.
Was ich ganz lustig fand, beim Transcriben, das hatte ich dir ja auch geschrieben,
ist das bei einer Folge, bei Folge 7, hatte ich Spaß und Zeit mal reingeschaut.
Das ist für mich immer so eine Demo-Folge, weil die Folge Nackt heißt.
Ob er irgendwas zensiert daran?
Nee, nee, aber es ist für mich einfach immer so die erste Folge,
um dich auszuprobieren, wenn ich irgendwas gemacht habe.
Warum auch immer. Und da war ja auch Jupp zu Gast.
Und wir haben beim Sprechen anfangs, da ist es mir zumindest aufgefallen,
wahrscheinlich auch in anderen Folgen, ziemlich viele Anglizismen verwendet
oder halt mal so einen Halbsatz komplett auf Englisch gesagt.
Und witzigerweise ist die Transcription Engine beim ersten Versuch dahergegangen
und hat das halt nicht eins zu eins transcribed, sondern wirklich übersetzt.
Und dann war da halt ein ganzer Absatz Englisch drin.
Das war halt nicht einfach nur mit einer englischen Engine deutsche Sprache
erkannt, sondern wirklich das Deutsch komplett so erkannt, wie es da war.
Und dann übersetzt ins Englische und dann ist der englische Text halt da reingeschrieben.
Das war total wild. Das ist ein Hinweis darauf, dass AI es schon in etwa so
funktionieren wie menschliche Gehirne.
Du weißt, du weißt den machen ja immer nicht, was du gehört hast.
Was mir passiert, was mir aufgefallen ist, ich weiß noch sehr genau,
als ich in den USA war als Austauschschüler, ist irgendwann dieser Moment eingetreten,
wo ich komplett auf Englisch umgestellt war, wo ich auch auf Englisch gedacht habe.
Und wenn ich in dem Moment, ich habe dann zum Beispiel nachts irgendwie geträumt
von Situationen mit alten Freunden aus Deutschland und in den Situationen haben
die Englisch gesprochen und wenn ich mich an Sachen erinnert habe,
die passiert sind, haben die Leute in meiner Erinnerung Englisch gesprochen und was,
in der, was ja übersetzt wird bei Whisper sind Tokens und dieses Token, das Token für,
Train und Zug sind halt an sich das gleiche Ja, was er übersetzt,
ja, soll ja nicht übersetzen und Whisper ist ja kein LLM oder kein...
Aber welche Sprache ist mir prinzipiell egal.
Ja, aber das ist ja wild, dass der überhaupt das kann, weil Whisper ist ja wie
gesagt nicht ein AI-Model, was eigentlich das versteht und verarbeitet,
sondern Whisper ist eine Transcription Engine,
also ein ML-Model, was trainiert ist, Sprache zu Text zu machen und nicht Verständnis drauf zu werfen.
Aber es ist nahe genug dran an dem Problem. Anscheinend oder?
Da steckt ja noch mehr drin, das kann halt aussehen, dass die Whisper auch Wenn
du GoToMeeting benutzt, was du wahrscheinlich nicht tust, aber was ich jeden
Tag benutze, weil meine Firma das baut, dann kannst du da auch Closed Captions unten anmachen.
Da haben wir auch bloß Whisper reingeschmissen.
Und da hast du das Problem, dass du nicht einfach sagen kannst,
nimm diesen gesamten Korpus-Text und transkribiere ihn, sondern du musst immer
mal wieder sagen, hier, chanke mal die letzten N Sekunden und das mal aber möglichst
auf kurzen Zeitfenstern, damit es nicht zu lange delayed ist.
Und du kannst nicht von Anfang an sagen, welche Sprache ist das.
Das heißt, du kannst dir wirklich sagen, du transkribierst Englisch.
Das heißt, es hat eine Spracherkennungsfunktion Und diese Spracherkennungsfunktion
sampelt ab und zu mal, welche Sprache geht an, auch mit einer gewissen Latenz, was den Effekt hat,
dass wenn ich mittendrin in einem Meeting, wenn ich Closed Captions anhabe, die Sprache wechsle,
dann transcribt er, was ich dann plötzlich auf Englisch sage,
trotzdem weiterhin auf Deutsch.
Aber ist er auch semantisch erkannt oder er hat einfach die falsche Spracherkennung
und dann kommt Garbage raus? Nee, nee, der übersetzt. Geil.
Das ist so wild, dass das passiert. Also an sich kannst du das,
ich weiß nicht, wo es aber explizit dazu geeignet ist, aber theoretisch könnte
ich mir vorstellen, dass du einfach sagen kannst, gib mir mal Closed Captions
in einer anderen Sprache.
Dafür ist es, das ist dem, glaube ich, möglich. Verrückt.
Was du übrigens auch machen kannst, ich weiß nicht, ob ihr das macht,
das habe ich letztens in einem Blogpost gelesen, fand ich ganz spannend,
von einer Person, die hat die OpenAI APIs für WSPA benutzt.
Kein Self-Hosted-Model, sondern das Gehostete.
Und hat da gemerkt, dass man die Audit-Daten vorher auch mit FFM-Pack einfach
auf zweifach beschleunigen kann und dann gegen die API wirft man nur die Hälfte
zahlt, weil einfach nur kurz, die halb so lang sind.
Also deine Berechnung ist in Länge, die du transkript. Genau,
du zahlst in Länge und... Weil theoretisch kannst du dann aus einem Speed-Up-Sample
würdest du genauso viele Informationstokens übersetzen, oder?
Theoretisch, wenn du das so verrechnest, aber ich kann mir halt auch vorstellen,
dass die Transkription im lokalen Modell halt auch nicht so lange dauert,
wenn du eine kürzere Audio-Datei benutzt, weil er halt dann schneller durchgearbeitet
ist oder so durch die Datei. Also ich weiß nicht genau, wie das funktioniert.
Ich weiß auch nicht, wie Whisper intern funktioniert anscheinend.
Also wenn das jetzt wirklich da irgendwie AI-augmented ist und Kram macht oder
so, dass es da noch irgendwie Kram drauf ist.
Also das ist ja auch, ich weiß gar nicht, Whisper ist glaube ich nicht Open Source, oder?
Ist es nicht in dieser Anwendung drin? Ich dachte schon.
Ich weiß ja nicht, ob die Binary Blocks für die Modelle halt irgendwie,
also die Binary Blobs kriegst du ja, aber ob da man da reinschauen kann,
was es macht, da habe ich keine Ahnung.
Also da würde ich mich aus dem Fenster legen, gefährliches Halbwissen,
hier was zu behaupten. Also nicht mal Halbwissen, eher so Nullwissen.
Es ist, glaube ich, Open Source OpenAI Whisper.
Gibt's auf GitHub. Ja, aber sind da jetzt, also, fragt mich nicht.
Schaut euch an, GitHub.com OpenAI Whisper. Ist von OpenAI übrigens.
War mir gar nicht so klar, aber natürlich ist alles von OpenAI.
Es gibt ja noch von NVIDIA jetzt eine ein neues Model zur Spracherkennung. Parakeet heißt das.
Das kann, glaube ich, aktuell nur Englisch, aber das ist krass.
Also das ist nochmal ein gutes Stück besser und performant. Also performant as fuck.
Also das transcribt dir gefühlt auf 20x die Folge durch.
Also nicht, dass die Audio-Datei auf 20x ist, sondern wie schnell das Ding halt
durch, die Folge durch, die Audio-Datei durch.
Also es fühlt sich unglaublich schnell an. So verboten schnell. Das ist beeindruckend.
Abgefahren. So, bevor wir jetzt in die Falle fallen, wie alle anderen,
dass wir nur noch über AI reden.
Nö, noch was anderes jetzt. Lass uns mal über noch was anderes reden.
Was hast du denn sonst in der letzten Zeit alles gemacht? Letzte Zeit ist ganz witzig.
Ich war jetzt eine Weile lang auf Android unterwegs, witzigerweise.
Was?
Aber ich sehe, du hast jetzt wieder die eckige Uhr um, also hast du es schon
wieder hinter dich gebracht.
So will ich es nicht sagen. Also ich habe mir im März gedacht,
ich brauche mal was anderes.
Das heißt, da hast du nicht deinen Job gekündigt oder irgendwie bist du umgezogen,
sondern du hast deinen...
Ich meinte, ich brauche mal was anderes in Bezug auf mobiles Betriebssystem.
Also es war ein sehr spezifischer Gedanke und ich habe ein bisschen geliebäugelt,
mittlerweile schon mal was anderes auszuprobieren und dachte,
die Zeit ist gekommen, hab mir ein Pixel zugelegt,
ein aktuelles, und hab mal ein bisschen darauf gelebt und war auch sehr happy, bin's auch immer noch.
Das Problem ist bloß, ich weiß jetzt auf beiden Seiten, was mir gefällt und
was nicht, und es gibt kein Betriebssystem, also es gibt ja eh nur die zwei
mobilen Betriebssysteme quasi, aber es gibt kein, also ja, es gibt noch ein
paar Outlier, okay, aber es gibt von dem... Gibt's Sailfish noch?
Ja, es gibt es gibt auch diverse Android Forks, die auch toll sind.
Es gibt jetzt hier ein KDE Mobile, gibt es jetzt wieder.
Ja, und mir hatte Marius mal so ein cooles, der hat so ein cooles Handy,
da läuft irgendein Desktop-Linux drauf in so einem Mobile-Modus.
Ich weiß nicht mehr genau, was es war, der hat mir das auf dem Kongress gezeigt. Mega cool.
Muss ich nochmal anfragen, was genau das war, was er da hat.
Aber ich weiß nicht, ob das Plasma Mobile war. Wahrscheinlich nicht.
Jedenfalls, es gibt also das ist ja auch, also geil. Ja, gar keine Frage.
Aber wenn ich jetzt mal, es ist, glaube ich, nicht falsch, wenn ich sage,
dass die Wahl auf Mobile, wenn du jetzt nicht gerade ein bisschen mehr Schmerzen
bereit bist aufzunehmen und du willst well supported sein und auf allen Seiten
halt, dass vieles funktioniert,
dann hast du die Wahl zwischen Android und iOS prinzipiell. Ja, ja.
Es gibt viele Sachen, die auf beiden Seiten fantastisch sind,
aber es gibt halt nichts, wo alles fantastisch ist.
Das kostet mich jetzt ein bisschen mehr und in die Scheißlage habe ich mich
halt so ein bisschen reingesetzt.
Aber ja, ich nutze jetzt gerade wieder iOS, aber ich mag auch manchmal einfach
ein bisschen Veränderung, habe ich gemerkt, was das angeht.
Und es macht einfach Spaß, was Neues zu probieren und es ist mit iOS 26 natürlich,
also ich habe jetzt die Beta eh schon installiert auf das Ding,
am Tag, wo es rauskam, weil da lag das ja eh nur daneben.
Das war ja noch meine Android-Phase.
Und dann dachte ich mir, da kannst du auch die Beta gleich draufwerfen.
Ich habe beides zu Hause in der Hand und ich bin mit beiden sehr glücklich.
Es gibt viele Dinge, die Android sehr, sehr gut macht.
Zum Beispiel, es fühlt sich einfach nur tausendmal schneller an.
Und das liegt einfach primär daran, dass ich die Animation-Speeds ändern kann.
Das ist eines der Features, was ich in KDE immer sehr geschätzt habe. Es ist so slappy.
Das ist geil. Und auf Android kann ich Firefox nutzen, mit Adblock und Cookie-Banner-Blocking,
weil da Extensions existieren.
Und auf iOS muss ich Safari nutzen, weil ich aber nicht mit dem Desktop synchronisiert bekomme.
Und Android kann so geil, das ist mehr so ein Hardware-Ding,
es kann so Dinge wie Battery-Share, dass ich halt Reverse-G-Charging mache und
meine Airpods, die problemlos mit Android funktionieren, hinten drauflege und
lade. Die Notifications sind der Hammer.
Und was ich glaube, am geilsten finde, ist tippen auf Android.
Ja, das hab ich auch so vermisst, ja. Fuck, ist die gut.
Du hast gerade quasi all die Sachen aufgezählt, die ich vermisst habe,
als ich vor drei Jahren auf iOS gewechselt bin.
Weil ich mir dachte, oh Gott, warum ist denn das so scheiße?
Das einzige, was die iOS-Tastatur besser macht, ist die Cursor Selection.
Die ist auf iOS geiler. Dass du auf der Leertaste halten kannst,
um den Cursor im ganzen Textfeld zu verschieben.
Auf Android kannst du halt nur links und rechts. Und du musst halt,
wenn du zwei Zeilen hoch willst, kannst du nicht nach oben, sondern du musst
halt so weit nach links, dass du zur nächsten Zeit kommst.
Aber das Swiping, also ich bin ja sehr, sehr ... Swipen zum Tippen, meinst du?
Ich kann das nicht auf Deutsch ausdrücken. Ich bin ja großer Swiper.
Ich swiper ja sehr gerne und das ging auf iOS wesentlich schlechter.
Da musste ich mir auch sehr viele Umwege, da musste ich mich auch lange dran
gewöhnen, dass das so unzuverlässig funktioniert.
Bis zu dem Punkt, dass ich mittlerweile sehr viele Nachrichten diktiere.
Also wenn du mal eine Nachricht von mir bekommst und die enthält Satzzeichen,
dann habe ich sie sehr wahrscheinlich diktiert.
Also mein ideales mobiles Betriebssystem wäre eine Mischung aus beidem.
Da würde Universal Back von Android drin sein, dass ich halt immer auf,
ich hab mir ja sehr schnell dran gewöhnt, von rechts zu schwecken.
Das wird genau in dem Moment passieren, wo der Markt dahin überschwenkt,
dass es für einen der beiden Marktteilnehmer nicht mehr interessant ist,
daran teilzunehmen und die quasi mergen und wenn dann entweder iOS oder Android
komplett 100% Marktanteil hat,
hast du für einen ganz kurzen Moment diesen Effekt, dass das das geilste System
ever ist und dann wird die Endstification eintreten, weil sie natürlich nicht
mehr mit Loginnehmen competen müssen.
Was ich, um noch ein paar Sachen mit anzusprechen, weil ich sie gerade noch
im Kopf habe und vor mir in der Liste habe, eine Sache, von der ich dachte,
dass ich sie sehr vermisse, ist Airdrop und Universal Clipboard.
Witzigerweise, dadurch, dass ich Tailscale nutze, was quasi so eine Art VPN
zwischen all meinen Devices ist, dass sich all meine Devices einfach untereinander
verletzt sind, egal wo sie sind, ich kann von meinem Server aus mein Handy anpingen,
und das geht problemlos.
Tailscale hat einen Feature-Namen, ist Tail Drop, was quasi so ein bisschen
Air Drop ist zwischen all meinen Geräten.
Und so kann ich einfach von meinem Rechner auf mein Handy und von meinem Handy
auf meinen Raspi Dateien droppen und empfangen.
Und das ging halt, das ist schneller als Air Drop, weil es halt die Verbindung
immer so instant hat und nicht erst noch wartet so, bist du da,
bist du da, bist du da, jetzt.
Obwohl Air Drop auch mit den Transfergeschwindigkeiten unglaublich schnell ist,
aber es ist schon, also meistens immer so ein Bild, was man sich schicken möchte.
Und witzigerweise, Universal Clipboard, was einfach ein tolles Feature ist,
dass du zwischen deinem iPhone und deinem Mac einfach, wenn du auf einem Gerät
Text kopierst, kannst du auf dem anderen Gerät pasten. Funktioniert wunderbar.
Ich habe auf meinem Mac KDE Connect installiert und auf dem Android-Gerät.
Und es läuft einfach stabiler.
KDE Connect ist super, das vermisse ich auch, seitdem ich keinen iOS mehr habe.
Wie kann das sein, dass das stabiler läuft als Apples eigenes Ding?
Du konntest KDE Connect benutzen, um aus deinem Telefon ein Touchpad zu machen. Ja, geil, Hammer.
Also das ist ganz wunderbar. Aber ansonsten, wie gesagt, ich nutze ja jetzt
aktuell wieder, Also es gibt noch ein paar mehr Punkte.
Ich wollte eigentlich noch einen Blogpost mal drüber schreiben,
wo ich wirklich mal so meine Gedanken alles so niederschreibe,
was mich gestört hat auf beiden Seiten, was ich toll finde auf beiden Seiten
und warum ich gerade iOS nutze.
Auch da gibt es natürlich viele tolle Dinge. Und eine Sache,
die ich halt, oder sagen wir mal, zwei Aspekte, die mir sehr wichtig sind, ist zum einen,
dass auf iOS sich tatsächlich, also das ist ein bisschen bauchgefühlig,
das gebe ich zu, aber Android-Apps sind sehr janky.
Und auf iOS laufen viele Sachen, vor allem halt Third-Party-Apps.
Weniger die First-Party-Apps, würde ich fast behaupten, aber vor allem die Third-Party-Apps.
Deutlich stabiler und du merkst, dass sie halt auch flotter laufen und das ist
ein Ding, was ich sehr genieße und andererseits eine Sache ist halt wirklich,
dass iOS sich ein gutes Stück sicherer anfühlt und das ist auch ein bisschen
Bauchgefühl, da ist natürlich viel dran und da kannst du auf Android auch viel
machen, indem du halt nicht mal erfüllst.
Ich weiß nicht mal, ob das mit dem iOS sicherer noch so wirklich wahr ist,
weil iOS sind jetzt die Letzten, die noch ihren Großteil ihres na boah,
das ist jetzt, ich lehne mich aus dem Fenster.
Ich meine, ich rede hier von sehr, also was ich sagen wollte,
ist, Android hat einen Großteil von seinem Stack mittlerweile von C und C++
wegportiert, das heißt, viele von diesen.
Memory-Einbruchstellen, wo die Leute irgendwelche Overflows in Bilder-Parsern
oder sowas oder in Bluetooth-Stacks exploiten, werden wahrscheinlich nicht mehr lange existieren.
Und macht iOS sowas?
Beschreibt iOS seine Treiber oder seine PNG-Pauser in Swift neu?
Werden wir das jemals erfahren? Sicherlich nicht.
Worauf ich aber auch ein bisschen mit dem Punkt hin möchte und ja,
ich weiß, ich lehne mich hier weit aus dem Fenster, was die Beurteilung von Android angeht.
Viele Leute nutzen halt Google Android und ich gebe es zu, ich habe auch Default
Android genutzt und auf einem Pixel, wo es wenigstens nicht mit Bloatware gefüllt ist.
Aber da war Google Software auch mit drauf und auch der Google Stack für Google
Barriere. Die Erfahrung ist
nochmal eine andere, wenn du ein Google-freies App hast. Auf jeden Fall.
Und wenn du dich da halt rauslämst und wie heißt es, ich höre mich nicht drauf.
Lineage? Gibt es das noch? Ne, das Ding, was primär auf Pixels läuft,
aber demnächst halt nicht mehr, weil Google die Device-Plops nicht mehr rausgibt.
Fuck, wie heißt denn das?
Ich habe es gleich. Graphino was.
Ich bin ja schon so weit raus, dass ich davon noch nie gehört habe.
Also wenn du Graphene OS nutzt, beziehungsweise du kannst auch sicherlich anderweitig
schon viel machen, aber du kannst halt dein Android sehr hardnen, gar keine Frage.
Und da kannst du sehr viel machen, damit das System wirklich ein komplett anderes ist.
Also das hat vor allem auch Google keinen Zugriff mehr auf dein Device hat.
Das ist schon mal der größte Aspekt.
Aber Graphene OS wird bald nicht mehr auf Pixelgeräten laufen.
Naja, das ist nochmal so eine andere Sache, dass Google selber jetzt in letzter
Zeit ein massives Arschloch ist und da jetzt die hatten vorher diese solche,
Blobs mit veröffentlicht, die Grafino S-Leute nutzen, um diese Compatibility
irgendwie sicherzustellen oder weiterzuentwickeln.
Ich kenne mich da auch nicht im Detail aus, wie genau das funktioniert,
aber die veröffentlicht Google jetzt nicht mehr für neue Geräte.
Und Grafino S ist halt nur kompatibel mit Pixel-Devices, wenn mich nicht alles
täuscht, aber in Zukunft müssen sie mal schauen, was sie da machen.
Also es kann sein, dass sie dann halt entweder jetzt mehr Support pushen für
andere Geräte, ob es jetzt Richtung Fairphone geht oder was auch immer.
Ich wollte gerade sagen, hast du dich mal ein bisschen mit Fairphones auseinandergesetzt?
Ich habe lange sehr viel verschiedene Hardware angeschaut, was es an coolen
Möglichkeiten gibt. Ich bin halt bürgerweise auch so ein Sucker für High-End-Hardware.
Also ich möchte ein schnelles Gerät mit der bestmöglichen Kamera und da fällt
halt schon vieles raus und was mich am meisten schockiert hat,
ist, dass die Flagship-Android-Geräte durch die Bank teurer sind als iPhones.
Wann ist das eigentlich passiert? Die kosten halt alle so 1200 bis 2000 Euro.
Das ist lächerlich, was du zahlst für so High-End-Android-Geräte.
Aber dafür gibt es halt auch Low-End-Android-Geräte. Dafür gibt es halt trotzdem
die komplette Bandbreite.
Also es gibt alles Mögliche. Aber wie gesagt, ich bin halt leider ein Sacker
für gute Hardware und dementsprechend wollte ich da halt auch was Tolles haben.
Ich habe lange überlegt, ob ich so ein Foldable-Device haben möchte,
was halt auch cool ist, aber es ist wahrscheinlich mehr Coolness-Faktor als wirklich sinnvoll.
War dann meine Vermutung. Denkst du, dass Foldable, das Android-Gadget des Jahres
ist oder wird das noch eine Weile bleiben?
Weiß ich nicht. Also das Problem an den meisten Foldables ist halt,
du hast entweder so ein Flip-Foldable, was weird ist und keiner wirklich braucht,
oder du hast so ein Quer-Foldable, was sich so ein Buch öffnen lässt,
im Formfaktor von einem normalen Smartphone.
Da hast du halt meistens draußen ein normales Smartphone-Display und drinnen
eins, was einfach groß und quadratisch ist.
Also wenn du ein Video schaust, bringt dir das überhaupt nichts,
wenn das quasi quadratisch ist. Dann hast du so Buchkant oder Querformat quasi das Gleiche.
Du hast halt eine gute Möglichkeit, da viel Webcontent beispielsweise anzuzeigen.
Aber gleichzeitig hast du, und das ist das, was für mich persönlich dagegen
gesprochen hat, über das Pixel-Fold zu gehen, ist, du hast halt dadurch,
dass es dich falten muss, drinnen kein gehärtetes Glas-Display.
Und wenn du zum Beispiel einmal ein Sandkorn dazwischen hast und klappst das
zu, dann ist das schon eine Marsch.
Und also es ist halt cool das stimmt, ja das ist nicht gehärtet,
weil es affordable ist, also vielleicht könnte man da auch irgendwie,
kombimäßig was machen, dass es in der Mitte irgendwie anders ist, keine Ahnung,
da werden sich Dinge auch weiterentwickeln noch auf die Zukunft Ich habe ja
dieses Mikrofasertuch, was eigentlich zum Reinigen von Spiegelreflexkameras
ist was aber exakt den Formfaktor von meinem Laptop hat Und das ist nicht das
Apple Mikrofasertuch für 30 Euro?
Nein, das ist für 15 Euro ein Dreierset Mikrofasertücher für für Spiegelreflexkameras gewesen.
Ich habe noch irgendwelches Reinigungs-Equipment dazu gekriegt,
was ich gar nicht brauche.
Aber in meinem Laptop ist immer schön dieses Kabel drin, äh dieses Tuch drin,
damit ich ja keine Fingerabdrücke auf dem Display habe.
Geil. Nee, aber also es gibt viel an Android-Geräten.
Ich habe viel durch die Hardware geschaut, lange Listen geschrieben und überlegt.
Da habe ich letztendlich für das Pixel 10 Pro entschieden gehabt und das kalt genommen.
Es gab vieles auch an Kleinigkeiten, die ich vermisst habe. Und da zählten vor
allem halt Third-Party-Apps dazu.
Primär Fantastical, weil auf Android gibt es einfach keinen guten Kalender. Sorry, ist so.
Also Business Calendar 2 ist 90 Prozent. Geil. Aber sonst gibt es einfach nichts Gutes.
Warum muss ich eine App nutzen, die Business Calendar 2 heißt? Stört mich.
Aber es gibt halt... Weil du die Lizenz für deine ganze Firma kaufst.
Genau, aber das ist eine gute App, gar keine Frage.
Aber es gibt halt etliche Sachen, die ein bisschen weird sind.
Ich habe immer Delayed Notifications gehabt.
Witzigerweise ist das Sharing von Firefox-Tabs auf iOS einfach geiler.
Also, was ist iOS? Die iPhones haben alle eine bessere Kamera. Auf iOS?
Auf Android? Nee, witzigerweise auf iOS. Wenn du dir von irgendwo irgendwas
teilen, was ich häufig mache, ist, ich habe irgendwas offen,
irgendwo im Browser oder was auch immer, und ich möchte mir eine URL an meinen
Desktop schicken, damit ich sie
später anschaue. Manchmal auf mein Arbeitsgerät, auf ein privates Gerät.
Auf iOS kannst du über die Share Extension an Firefox sharen,
dann geht quasi ein Pop-Up auf, so ein Overlay-Window, ich wäre witzig,
dass ich das überhaupt machen könnte, und dann kannst du ausführen,
an welche Geräte es geschickt wird.
Auf Android musst du immer das dumme Tab erst in Firefox öffnen,
dann auf den Tab-Button, dann auf den Share-Button und dann kannst du ein Gerät
auswählen, bevor es wieder zugeht.
Und das ist einfach ein bisschen, also die User Experience da ist ein bisschen
beschissener als auf iOS. Das ist einfach so eine Kleinigkeit,
ich habe mich aufgeregt.
Dann so Sachen wie, dass du auf iOS einfach überall Bilder kopieren und einfügen
kannst. Das geht auf Android einfach nicht. Du kannst überall einen Longpress auf ein Bild machen.
Also das bringt quasi jede App mit. Du kannst überall Bilddaten in die Clipboard nehmen.
Ist aber auf Android einfach kein Ding. Es wird nicht sauber supportet.
Vor allem, dass du in der Chat-App dann einfach das Bild pasten kannst,
musst du versenden. Das mache ich ständig.
Und also so Kleinigkeiten, an denen ich mich ein bisschen aufgerieben habe,
vieles ist natürlich geil, vieles ist... Also auf beiden Seiten, vieles toll.
Auf beiden Seiten, vieles beschissen. Was ich tatsächlich relativ häufig benutze,
ist tatsächlich Continuity.
Ich habe jetzt hier einen Tab auf meinem Firefox, auf dem Telefon offen,
und im Dock sehe ich bereits unten, oh, du hast hier ein Firefox auf deinem
Telefon offen, mach doch den Tab von dort hier auf.
So kann man es auch machen, ja. Ich bin meistens gefühlt nicht an beiden Systemen gleichzeitig.
Also wenn ich am Desktop sitze, mache ich quasi nichts am Handy.
Aber diese Ansicht mit den Tabs von dem anderen Gerät sind auch nochmal super
praktisch. Ja, absolut.
Ansonsten, was mir natürlich das Leben stark erleichtert hat,
ist, dass ich so Sachen nutze wie Beeper, also dass ich eh alles an Chat in
einer App habe, die plattformübergreifend gut funktioniert und da ist.
Ich habe aber auch die Migration zu Android genutzt und das hat mir tatsächlich
sehr viel Spaß gemacht und auch nachhaltig, glaube ich, viel gegeben,
ist, dass ich meine Daten quasi ein bisschen befreit habe.
Also ich habe... Bist ein bisschen raus aus dieser iCloud. Genau,
genau. Also ich habe meinen Kalender und meine Kontakte zum Beispiel waren bisher
alle in iCloud drin. Sind sie nicht mehr.
Die habe ich jetzt selber in der Hand. Ah ja.
Also ich hoste sehr viel selber, ja. Zum Beispiel Mail läuft nach wie vor über
Fastmail, das war vorher nie anders, also seit 10 Jahren ist das da mein Kalender
ist nicht mehr bei iCloud der ist jetzt auch bei Fastmail witzigerweise.
Bilder ich habe meine iCloud nicht aufgegeben, weil sich quasi noch so ein bisschen
Backup für mich darstellt und sie auch nach wie vor aber ich habe mir so ein
Image selber gehostet, was,
unglaublich fantastisches da könntest du nochmal eine gesondert drüber reden
also holy fuck ist das gut das ist so unglaublich gut, ich habe mich leider
mittendrin einmal selbst zerschossen, da bin ich ein bisschen selber dran schuld, weil ich,
noch ein bisschen mehr mit dem Setup da gemacht habe, was im Untergrund noch
mal was, ein bisschen mehr... Was ist Immig?
Immig ist quasi self-hosted Google Fotos slash iCloud Fotos,
so wie ich gleich sagen kann.
Und wo hast du das drauf laufen? Auf deinem NAS? Auf dem Home-Server, genau.
Ich habe einen Server zu Hause, das ist einfach so ein kleiner Mini-PC,
der einfach noch mit unserem Schreibtisch steht und da läuft diverses an Software
drauf, einfach, da ist einfach NixOS drauf und da drauf läuft mal Docker und
mit Docker Compose host, ich meine jetzt Sachen, eigentlich alles selber,
wollte ich auch mal irgendwie migrieren und anders machen, aber das ist fein
so, das ist voll toll und ich habe viel auf meinem Homeserver laufen und damit
bin ich sehr, sehr glücklich und da komme ich nachher in dem Pick nochmal drauf
zu sprechen, was das Setup sehr viel cooler macht und sehr viel viel mehr.
Oh, wir haben Picks? Da kommen wir nachher noch zu. Ähm,
Aber da läuft es bei Immig, da läuft auch sowas wie in Paperless,
da läuft auch noch diverse andere Software.
Aber ich wollte es nicht übertreiben und weil vor allem ich weiß,
dass wenn ich viel da hinschmeiße, Dinge weniger maintainen möchte.
Das war absolut kein korrektes Deutsch, aber ihr wisst, was ich meine.
Aber Immig ist einfach unglaublich gute Software, vor allem weil es Machine
Learning, Erkennung und Bildersuche hat, die einfach besser ist als das,
was iCloud und vor allem besser ist als das, was Google hat.
Das ist für mich das Hauptfeature, weshalb ich die iCloud-Fotos benutze. Absolut.
Ich brauche genau drei Sachen für eine Bilderdatenbank.
Ich möchte suchen können mit Machine Learning Models. Ich eingebe Katze und finde Katzenfotos.
Ich möchte eine Karte sehen können von allen Fotos, weil meistens,
wenn ich ein Bild suche, ich weiß, wo das entstanden ist, aber ich weiß nicht,
wann das entstanden ist.
Ich möchte auf eine Karte reinzoomen können, auf alle Bilder,
die ich dort und dort gemacht habe und dann raussuchen können.
Und ich möchte, wenn ich irgendwo in der Kartenansicht oder so,
und das ist wirklich ein Killerfeature für mich, aber das können ausschließlich
gefühlt Immig und iCloud und sonst nichts.
Ich bin über die Kartenansicht oder über die Suche in ein Bild gekommen,
dann möchte ich auf diesem Bild auswählen können, Show in all Fotos und da in
die Timelines jumpen können, um den Kontext um dieses Bild drumherum zu sehen.
Manchmal, wenn ich Bilder suche, weiß ich, ich habe zum Beispiel mit dir zusammen
ein Foto gemacht, ich suche irgendein spezifisches Bild von dir,
finde es nicht oder ich weiß, dass du nur von hinten drauf bist,
nur so random als Beispiel, du machst gerade ein Foto von uns.
Super gutes Beispiel. Ich suche ein Bild von dir von hinten.
Ich weiß, das hat die Erkennung nie erkannt, weil dein Gesicht nicht drauf ist.
Aber ich weiß, dass ich im Kontext davon, vielleicht ist es im Countdown entstanden
oder so, dann kann ich Fotos vom Countdown anschauen.
Und dann finde ich da ein Bild von dem Abend und dann gehe ich in All Photos
und finde das Bild drei Bilder davor.
Und ich brauche halt diesen kontextuellen Weg, weil das ist für mich so 80%
der Zeit, wie ich mit Bildern... Und Show in All Photos gibt es in Google Fotos nicht?
Ne, soweit ich weiß, gibt es das nicht. Also korrigiert mich bitte,
wenn ich falsch liege. Ist mir auch egal.
Also, ne, das geht nicht wahr. Antwortet uns mal, ob ihr überhaupt Google Fotos
benutzt, weil ich könnte mir vorstellen, dass unsere Zuhörer Google Fotos wahrscheinlich...
Ja, oder wenn ihr halt andere Sachen nutzt, aber es gibt ja noch zig andere
Möglichkeiten oder man hat einfach eine Galerie auf dem Handy,
aber das bringt halt nicht diese Möglichkeiten mit, die ich halt suche.
Ich möchte Gesichtserkennung, ich möchte eine ML-basierte Suche auf Daten,
ich möchte eine Karte, ich möchte diese Show-and-All-Fotos und dann bin ich halt wirklich happy.
Und in mich bringt das alles fantastisch gut mit, also wirklich unglaublich gut.
Das ist viel zu gute Software dafür, dass es Open-Source ist.
Naja, da wird wahrscheinlich trotzdem irgendjemand drei Euro mitverdienen, oder?
Naja, du kannst eine Lizenz kaufen, die bringt dir halt nichts extra,
aber die sagen dir halt damit, dass du es supporten kannst. Und ich hoffe,
dass es auch sustainable ist für die Leute.
This project is under very active development.
Expect bugs and changes. Sie haben auch immer wieder breaking changes in den Updates.
Du musst halt die Updates nicht mitmachen, aber du solltest halt schon schauen
und regelmäßig up to date bleiben, weil du die mobilen Apps,
die du nutzen kannst, die auch teilweise halt sagen, hey, die mobile App,
diese Version funktioniert noch mit dieser Version vom Server.
Also du musst da halt schon, also du kannst es nicht komplett ignorieren.
Was ich zum Beispiel, ein Feature, mal als Kundenanfrage.
Ich benutze von Synology diese Fotos-App,
einzig und allein, um alle meine Fotos jederzeit vom Telefon runter auf meinen
NAS auch nochmal zu spiegeln. Als Backup.
Synology hat auch so eine Fotos-App, die ich nicht benutze. Ja,
die kann auch literally gar nichts.
Es ist auch Wurst, muss bloß irgendwie immer wieder vom Telefon runter auf das
NAS geschoben werden, falls irgendwie iCloud in Europa verboten wird. Oder irgend sowas.
Kann ja immer passieren. Und nochmal Android vs. iOS.
Ein Feature oder Anwendung, die ich auf iOS nicht haben kann,
die ich von Android gewohnt bin, weil sie auf iOS verboten sind,
sind Background Services.
Das heißt, du kannst nicht sagen, diese App, die Fotos-App von so und so startet
und weiß und wird aufgeweckt jedes Mal, wenn ein Foto gemacht wird,
auch wenn ich das nicht zufällig als Kamera oder sowas verwende und synchronisiert
einfach immer, ohne dass ich es explizit machen muss,
meine Fotos von meinem Telefon runter auf mein NAS.
Dazu muss ich die App immer starten und eine Weile laufen lassen und wenn sie
ausgeht und dann ist es zu Ende. Also prinzipiell hast du recht,
es gibt keine Background-Services auf iOS.
Das ist geil, dass sie auf Android existieren, weil du es da halt auch sehen
kannst, dass der KDE Connect im Hintergrund läuft oder was halt sonst.
Aber was iOS kann, sind Apps, die halt regelmäßig aufwachen und Dinge machen im Hintergrund.
Also die Synology-App, Foto-App sollte definitiv in der Lage sein,
regelmäßig im Hintergrund mal zu schauen.
Das Problem ist nur, dass iOS da halt ein bisschen versucht,
in Anführungsstrichen schlau zu sein und eine App seltener weckt,
wenn du sie weniger benutzt.
Und gerade in dem Fall ist das sinnlos. Eben, gerade weil du diese App halt nie aufmachst.
Das habe ich mal gehabt zum Beispiel. Es kann sein, dass die sogar mittlerweile
wieder deinstalliert ist oder ausgelagert ist, weil ich sie natürlich lange
nicht benutzt habe. Das ist halt auch so ein Feature, was sowohl iOS als auch
Android per Default machen.
Beziehungsweise, wenn ich Android sage, ich meine die ganze Zeit halt einfach
Stock Android, Stock Google Android.
Es kann sein, dass andere Folks und Custom-Rombs das anders machen.
Aber was Android slash iOS beide machen, ist so ein Feature mitbringen.
Auf iOS ist es, glaube ich, per Default aus, dass sie so Apps auslagern können
oder halt Settings-mäßig zurücksetzen können.
Android nimmt zum Beispiel Apps Permissions weg und sie lange nicht benutzt. Finde ich gut.
Aber was halt mir mal passiert auf iOS, ich hatte dieses Feature einmal angemacht,
dass es Apps auslagert, die ich häufig nicht benutze und was halt als erstes
gemacht hat, hat diese Withings App gleich mal runtergehauen,
die aber ausschließlich auf einem Gerät installiert ist, damit sie regelmäßig
im Hintergrund mal kurz mit meiner Waage spricht und die Daten holt und in Apple Health speichert.
Und das hat es halt instant nicht mehr gemacht und es ist mir Monate später
aufgefallen, dass die Daten halt fehlen, weil ich diese App nicht einmal geöffnet
habe, seitdem ich sie einmal installiert und reingerichtet habe.
Das wäre auch nochmal ein Thema, wo wir uns nochmal on the air drüber unterhalten
könnten, zu Gesundheits-Apps und was wir da benutzen. Aber ein anderes mal.
Was zum Beispiel auch nicht auf iOS geht, was ich auf Android früher sehr häufig
genutzt habe, sind so banale Wecker-Apps.
Ich hatte eine Wecker-App, als ich noch Android benutzt habe,
die mich morgens gezwungen hat, irgendwelche Rechenaufgaben zu lösen.
Und du konntest halt, du hattest einen Radio-Wecker, der morgens einen bestimmten Stream angemacht hat.
Und wenn ich das heute haben möchte, muss ich der ARD-Audiothek-Apps sagen,
ich möchte morgen geweckt werden, dann muss ich die anlassen. Ja, nee, das geht nicht.
Das ist Quark. Vor allem, weil du teilweise auch den Screen anlassen musst.
Da musst du den Screen anlassen?
Nee. Also was geht, was tatsächlich auch, das ist witzigerweise auch ein Ding,
was ich auf iOS mehr mag als auf Android, ist, wie ich mit dem Stockwecker Dinge automatisieren kann.
Auf iOS lasse ich mich von Musik wecken, wenn ich snooze.
Und da hast du zum Beispiel Automation hooked über die Shortcuts-App.
Genau, sowas habe ich mir dann auch angefangen zu basteln. Da musst du dann
wieder eine Radio-App finden, die auch automatisierbar ist. Die sind alle unmaintained
und scheiße. Also da hast du wahrscheinlich schon Pech, dass das geht.
Genau. Aber über Apple Music kannst du im Hintergrund... Apple Music übrigens
fantastisch auf Android läuft.
Ist super. Ist großartig. Apple hat es auch für Android rausgebracht. Läuft wunderbar.
Das finde ich die beste Musik-App auf Android. Ähm...
Wenn du damit Radio hören möchtest, geht es trotzdem über Tuning.
Das ist so ein Feature, was zum Beispiel... Du bist halt so ein Mensch, der Radio hören möchte.
Das ist gefühlt, das ist blöd, aber das ist gefühlt in der heutigen Welt ein
esoterischer Wunsch schon geworden.
Also es ist kacke, dass dem so ist, aber da brauchst du halt gefühlt...
Also das macht einfach niemand mehr klingelt.
Ich habe noch in der Küche zum Kochen, oder frühmorgens mache ich das Radio
an, indem ich da der Alexa sage, spiel diesen Radiosender und dann spielt es
diesen Radiosender und es spielt die Tagesschau in 100 Sekunden.
Wenn du sagst, spiel die Tagesschau in 100 Sekunden, das macht kein anderes Gerät.
Das macht der HomePod von Apple nicht.
Ja, nee, das ist komfortabel auf jeden Fall, gar keine Frage.
Und also für mich persönlich passt der Workflow auf iOS mit dem Wecker besser,
weil auf Android mit dem normalen Wecker konnte ich halt sowas machen wie ich
möchte Musik bekommen, wenn nicht zum Wecken.
Aber dann ist sie halt ausgegangen in dem Moment, wenn ich Snooze gedrückt habe
oder wie ich sie ausgemacht habe.
Aber was ich eigentlich möchte, ist genau das, was ich auf iOS hingekriegt habe.
Wenn der Wecker klingelt, klingelt der Wecker. Aber wenn ich auf Snooze drücke,
soll die Musik loslaufen.
Damit ich beim Snoozen Musik habe, nur wenn ich zu Hause bin,
das kann ich über Shotguns vielleicht mit automatisieren. Kann man seine Shotguns
eigentlich irgendwo publishen?
Ja, ein paar Leute haben da mal so Webseiten gebaut, wo du das machen kannst.
Nichts davon, soweit ich weiß, wird durchgestattet. Wenn es eine GitHub für
iOS Automations gäbe, ich würde dir folgen.
Du, ich habe ein GitHub-Repo, wo ich ein paar Shotguns veröffentlicht habe.
Aber das ist alt. Das kommt hier in die Show Notes. Hauptsächlich für mich.
Ich muss mal aussuchen, ob ich das überhaupt noch finde.
Aber, also, die Shortcuts basteln ist auch ein bisschen Shit.
Was witzigerweise, ich dachte ja, beim Wechsel zu Android, das ist bestimmt viel geiler.
Hab mir Tasker installiert und bin kläglich dran gescheitert.
Also, das ist einfach unglaublich mächtig, gar keine Frage.
Was ist Tasker? Ist das quasi Shortcuts für Android? Quasi, genau.
Es ist aber, also, es kam auch schon viel früher raus, gar keine Frage,
das will ich ja gar nicht in Frage stellen.
Es ist unglaublich mächtig, aber damit was zu machen, ist sauschwierig und vor
allen Dingen in, sagen wir mal, moderne Apps, die nicht davon ausgehen, dass das möglich ist.
Also du kannst damit Activities launchen, ja, und du kannst krassen Kram machen.
Und es gibt ja auf Android auch, wo muss ich mich jetzt erstmal aeneinandersetzen,
wenn ich jetzt die Öffi installiert habe, habe ich ja drei Apps installiert,
also drei Activities in dieselbe App, die du launchen kannst.
Das war einfach alles immer so, das geht, wie funktioniert das überhaupt?
Und wollte ich einfach so ein bisschen verstehen, wie das technisch überhaupt
gelöst ist und wie so eine App gestrukturiert ist.
Also ich komme ja auch aus der iOS-Dev-Schiene. Ich nutze ja iOS aus dem Wissen
von einer Person, die für diese Plattform entwickelt und verstehe auch so quasi,
was so die Möglichkeiten sind.
Und das hat mir auf Android einfach komplett gefehlt. Das war erstmal komplett
wild überhaupt, das dann nachvollziehen zu können, wie das System funktioniert.
Und ja, mit Tasker kannst du halt krassen Shit machen, gar keine Frage,
habe ich nicht hinbekommen.
Aber ist das hier wirklich die Tasker-Webseite? Bin ich da richtig?
Total Automation für Android. Das ist die Tasker-Webseite. Sieht halt auch aus
wie... Sieht halt auch aus wie 2005.
Also, aber Shortcuts Das kann halt auch unerwartet viel auf iOS,
also diese Automation-Hooks, du kannst einen Hook hängen an,
es wird ein Hund bellt oder die Klingel läuft, was geil ist für Leute, die heiß im Pair sind.
Das Problem bei Shortcuts auf iOS ist, es ist nicht discoverable, nicht wirklich.
Also diese App ist einfach nicht zugänglich.
Nö, es ist ein Power-User-Feature, gar keine Frage. Und was da jetzt quasi das
große Shortcoming, jetzt sind wir wieder bei AI, das große Shortcoming von Apple ist,
die hätten, also ich hätte mir gewünscht, dass es einen Agent gibt,
der mir aus menschlicher Sprache Automations zusammenbaut.
Ich könnte mir vorstellen, dass das tatsächlich noch kommt.
Klar, das müsste halt, okay, muss nicht unbedingt von Apple kommen.
Es gibt sogar Leute, die haben so eine Swift-DSL für Shortcuts geschrieben,
dass du dir quasi aus Swift-Code heraus Shortcuts kompilieren kannst.
Das Ding ist halt, Shortcuts zu bauen ist, wie gesagt, mühsam,
weil du durch diese UI klicken musst.
Und du musst halt mit, du musst halt, ich weiß nicht, ob ihr das mit Erfahrung
habt, wenn ihr hier zuhört, aber ich habe früher mal mit diesem Lego-Toolkit
Dinge gebaut, wo man mit Lego-Mindstorms so Code in Blöcken zusammengeschoben hat.
Da hast du so einen If-Block da reingezogen und dann einen Loop-Block.
Graphical Programming. So was.
Und so fühlt sich das in Shortcuts an. Und das ist so unglaublich mühsam,
wenn du was Komplexeres basteln möchtest.
Für kleine Sachen reicht es völlig aus. für Komplexeres.
Nee, da gibt es hier die Kugel, bevor du das machst. Das ist einfach scheiße.
Und da wäre es tatsächlich geil, wenn das halt irgendein AI-Agent machen kann
und zumindest wenn du halt weißt, hier, ich habe hier,
ich weiß, ich muss hier drei Loops nesten, um irgendwas zu machen und dafür
die Variablen hier oben definieren, das ist einfach,
drecksumständlich, weil du das ja auch reindragen musst, du kannst ja auch ein
Mac auch machen in der Shortcuts-App und es dann rüber sinken,
ist trotzdem nicht besser, aber wenn das halt ein Agent einfach machen könnte,
weil du dem sagst, hier, ich weiß genau, wie die Struktur aussehen muss,
du musst nicht mal viel denken, das ist einfach nur,
Boilerplate, die Mühe wegnehmen, das wäre ja auch schon mal ein Mehrwert.
Das wäre cool, wenn das geht. Vielleicht kann man sowas tatsächlich sogar Third-Party-Mätig machen.
Muss man mal drüber nachdenken. Man müsste mal was bauen. Müsste man mal bauen.
Das ist unser klassisches, man müsste, wir können das als Kategorien,
ich höre ja andere Podcasts und denke mir so, ich hätte gerne wieder so Segmente.
Diese Segmente-Picks halten wir einigermaßen durch, aber ich hätte gerne auch
so das Segment, man müsste mal was bauen.
Was müsste man mal bauen? Genau das müsste man mal bauen, so was noch fehlt.
Wir nehmen noch einen Jingle auf und spielen es jetzt an dieser Stelle ein.
Wir haben es im Pad, müssen wir mal bauen, Shortcut Agent.
Ich habe gerade bei ChatGPT gefragt und der sagt, you can ask ChatGPT to generate
Apple Shortcuts as JSON- or PLIST-Format.
Ich zweifle das sehr an, dass da eine valide PLIST rausfällt.
Aber ja, klar, wenn es ein bisschen Handstreich ist. Es ist ja auch,
also das Format ist nicht unglaublich komplex.
Man kann es lesen. Wie nennt sich eigentlich dieser Effekt? also es gibt JavaScript-Fatigue
als Begriff, aber wie nennt sich, gibt es auch AI-Fatigue, diesen Effekt, dass du zwar weißt,
dass dir AI was generieren kann auf deiner Anfrage, aber du jetzt schon weißt,
dass es nicht funktionieren wird. Ja klar.
So ist das irgendwie Slop-Fatigue oder so. So können wir es nennen, gerne.
Ja, also dieses, was hatte ich neulich auf Arbeit, wir hatten was gemalt mit
Excalibur, ich liebe Excalibur, aber theoretisch dürfen wir es nicht benutzen,
wir hatten nur leider in dem Moment schon eine relativ komplexe Grafik da reingezaubert.
Und dann habe ich das genommen als Bild und habe das in unser Chat-JPT reingeschoben
und gesagt, mach mir doch mal bitte DrawIO draus. Und dann habe ich gesagt, kein Problem.
Und dann hat er angefangen, irgendwie 300 Zeilen XML zu generieren,
die ich dann in DrawIO hätte importieren können oder versucht habe zu importieren.
Und natürlich hat es nichts gerendert.
Also wer weiß, wo das Bild war, irgendwie drei Milliarden Pixel weiter nach
links oder sowas. es war dann einfach leer, obwohl es halt eine ziemlich große Datei war.
Und das ist halt der Moment, wo du denkst, nee, ich debugge das jetzt nicht.
Weshalb ich beim... Kennst du den Image-to-Draw-IO-Converter?
Nee. Witzigerweise hat das Julius letztens rumgeschickt. Ich hätte fast gedacht
nach der Aussage jetzt, dass das sogar über Ecke von dir kam.
Aber ich kann mir mit, wie ich schon was packen. Da kannst du eine Bilddatei
reinpacken und das gemacht daraus.
Draw-IO nutzt auch AI on the hood. Ob es funktioniert, keine Ahnung.
Der Begriff Vibe-Coding ist ja auch wirklich abgehangen mittlerweile und was
ich immer mehr sehe, ist so Tipps
zum Vibe-Coden, wie man es richtig macht oder wie man es besser macht.
Ein paar davon sind sinnig, das ist das Beispiel, gutes Vibe-Coding sind eigentlich
gutes Software-Engineering, Feuerplan, Strukturieren, kleine erfüllbare Aufgaben,
Check-Ins und so weiter.
Als ich hier diese Podcast Search gebaut habe, habe ich auch am Anfang irgendwie ganz kurz.
Mit Claude gemacht, habe ich gesagt bauen wir das mal zusammen ich hätte gerne
so und so, was kann man denn da nehmen,
zum Thema, ich habe hier ganz viele Transcripts, die würde ich gerne irgendwo
reinschieben und dann habe ich gerne ein Webinterface, wo ich eine Suche an
ein LLM stellen kann, das mir dann inhaltliche Fragen zu diesen Transcripts
beantwortet und das vielleicht auch zusammenfasst und dann gesagt,
naja, du kannst das nehmen, das nehmen, das nehmen und übrigens,
ich schreibe dir jetzt mal so ein ganzes Python-Script und dann geht bei Claude
ja an der Seite irgendwie so ein Dings auf,
wo dann anfängt irgendwie Python auszukotzen.
Ja, und dann hat er das da hingeschrieben und das sieht aus.
Und du denkst so, wow, und dann faltet das wieder zu und dann kannst du das
nehmen und musst nur noch das machen und wenn du das machst,
dann nimmst du dieses Skript, führst es aus und dann geht's.
Und dann nimmst du dir dieses generierte 120-Zeilen-Python-Script,
paste das irgendwas rein und es passiert irgendwas Falsches und du denkst dir,
fuck, jetzt habe ich hier.
120-Zeilen-Code, die ich nicht kenne, nicht verstehe, denen ich nicht vertraue,
weil sie noch nie funktioniert haben und die ich jetzt debuggen muss.
Ja, viel Spaß. Furchtbar.
Und dann gibt es halt Leute, ich weiß nicht, wie man dann,
man kann ja falsch rangehen an dieses Problem und sagen, nee,
warte mal, ich sehe jetzt diesen Error,
iterier mal und dann lässt du die AI den ersten und dann kann es halt sein,
dass du ewig lang im Kreis rennst und immer wieder den nächsten Fehler fixen
lässt und ich habe gesagt, da habe ich aber jetzt überhaupt keinen Bock drauf,
sondern ich habe gesagt, pass auf, ich will das selber machen und du sollst
mir das nicht einfach generieren,
wir machen jetzt einen Plan und du gibst mir Schritt für Schritt,
Baustein für Baustein jede einzelne Funktion, damit es überhaupt funktioniert.
Also sagen wir mal so, ich habe jetzt die Transkripte, ich möchte dir erstmal,
ich muss dir wahrscheinlich in irgendeine Datenbank schieben,
wie baue ich denn die Datenbank drauf? Und da hat er mir zehn Zeilen Python-Funktion.
Und ich habe gesagt, wie teste ich denn das? Kann ich das in einer interaktiven
Python-Share einfach so ausführen?
Ja, dann musst du natürlich einfach das Python starten und import bla bla bla
from PodcastPile und dann kannst du es ausführen.
Und dann habe ich das gemacht und dann hat er schon mal eine Viertelstunde gerüttelt
und alles importiert. Und dann konnte ich mir das hinterher anzeigen lassen
und es hat funktioniert.
Da habe ich gesagt, gut, okay, check, das funktioniert. Jetzt hätte ich gerne
so und so. Und dann habe ich mich wirklich eine Dreiviertelstunde bis Stunde.
Interaktiv mit dem Ding wirklich unterhalten und mir immer nur kleine Schnipsel
geben lassen und jeden einzelnen Schritt gecheckt, dass der auch funktioniert.
Genauso soll man, das ist ja, wie du schon vorher gesagt hast,
so machst du ja ordentliche Softwareentwicklung.
Du kotzt nicht einfach irgendwas hin, was prinzipiell alles machen könnte,
nur halt nicht funktioniert am Ende und nicht verifizierbar ist,
sondern du gehst halt planungsmäßig irgendwie Schritt für Schritt durch,
du machst dir Gedanken, was logische Einheiten sind und du probierst halt aus,
dass die auch funktionieren Schritt für Schritt.
Und dann versteht man auch, was die Anwendung tut und das finde ich auch so
funktioniert sinnvolle Arbeiten mit AI.
Aber dann verstehe ich nicht, warum der Default von vielen dieser Chatbots ist,
dass der erstmal einem, das geht mir auch auf den Sack, also je nachdem,
welches Frontend du verwendest.
Ich benutze jetzt im Code mittlerweile Z, kann ich auch noch in Ruhe drüber
reden, aber wenn der dann anfängt, was zu schreiben und du liest die ersten
Zeilen und dann macht er und hoppst so hoch und du kommst mit dem Lesen nicht
hinterher, weil er immer wieder hochhoppst und unten das neue Rand schreibst
und selbst wenn du scrollst, das ist da kaputt.
Du kannst nicht runterscrollen, bis nicht die eine Seite voll ist.
Ich weiß nicht, warum dann der Default ist, dass ihr irgendwie mehrere Bildschirmseiten
auf einmal bei der ersten Frage sofort auskotzt. Also die meisten Chat-Implementations,
die ich kenne, machen das mittlerweile genauso.
Die scrollen so lange, bis die erste Seite gefüllt ist und dann scrollen sie
out of screen weiter oder tippen out of screen. Dann wird weitergeneriert out of screen.
Was aber witzigerweise, was ich auch noch gerade sagen wollte...
Ich schreibe mittlerweile bei meinem Prompt schon dazu, briefly oder nur ganz
wenig. Das kannst du in deine Pre-Prompt mit reinschreiben.
Und bitte zeigt mir nicht den gesamten Code, du musst den nicht wiederholen,
weil der muss ja auch erstmal erzeugt werden, das kostet ja auch Kontext und
Tokens und so weiter, sondern nur Diffs oder so, oder was relevant ist.
Was witzigerweise aber in die Richtung geht von wegen warum das Hinkotzen ist,
du hast ja meistens so eine Art Chat-Interface in der Hand und da geht es halt,
du gibst eine Nachricht rein und da kommt halt eine Antwort raus und die Antwort
soll ja auch möglichst all-encompassing sein und die Antwort darauf sein und
die Antwort enthält dann halt alles.
Wenn du sowas nutzt wie Cloud Code zum Beispiel, das ist sicherlich auch einen
großen Teil der System.com zu verdanken, aber was das Ding halt macht, ist.
Baut sich erstmal eine To-Do-Liste und schaut sich nach, was sind hier logische
Schritte, die sofort werden müssen.
Und da kannst du halt theoretisch auch hier ein bisschen stupider reingehen,
aber du kannst auch diesen Action-Plan auch Schritt für Schritt dann besser
durchgehen und durchsteigen und verstehen halt, was da passiert mit jedem Diff für jeden Diff.
Und dann wird halt auch nicht unbedingt alles auf einmal erzeugt,
sondern du kannst dich halt mit dem Ding zusammen langerhandeln.
Das ist ein bisschen angenehmer in der Nutzung als das Chat-Interface zur Code-Erzeugung.
Aber das ist halt alles nur eine Tool-Frage. Das heißt, eigentlich benutzt man
das falsche Tool, wenn man zum Beispiel ChatGPD verwendet, weil weil es einem
einfach dann die gesamte Antwort auf einmal geben möchte? Möchte vor allem, ja.
Also das ist aber, wie gesagt, am LLM dahinter ändert das nicht viel.
Klar, es gibt ein paar Modelle, die besser trainiert sind auf Code-Erzeugung
als andere, aber das ist quasi nur qualitativ, glaube ich, der Unterschied, was dabei rausfällt.
Aber ansonsten ist das eher so eine Frage von dem Tool, was du drumherum rappst.
Und das ist einfacher, zum Beispiel so ein CLI-Tool wie Codex von OpenAI oder
Gemini CLI oder Cloud Code oder halt auch eins von den Wappern für ULAMA-Interfaces und andere.
Mittlerweile gibt es ja, es gibt so etwas wie das Cloud-Router,
da kannst du dein Cloud-Code rappen, damit du es an andere Modelle,
die Fragen schickst. Aber trotzdem das Cloud-Tooling, was auch total cool ist.
Aber wir driften schon wieder in die ER-Richtung. Ja, nichts zu weg.
Zumindest der Begriff, den ich gesucht habe, ist noch zu suchen.
Vielleicht frage ich einfach mal Chachipiti, wie das heißt. Nein,
Slop. Ich nenne es einfach Slop-Fatigue. Slop-Fatigue.
Eine Sache, die ich ganz witzig fand, habe ich das in einem Hacker-News-Kommentar
gelesen, ist, das AI-Output ist wie ein Traum.
Meinen eigenen, meinen eigens generierten finde ich total spannend und krass,
was der kann, aber in Scheißen interessiert mich der von anderen Leuten.
Schick mir nicht deine AI-Antwort mal. Das ist eine andere Variante von Slop-Fatigue.
Wenn ich irgendwo Content sehe oder Texte, wenn ich weiß, dass das AI generiert
ist, dann brauche ich es nämlich lesen. Das kann ich doch selber erzeugen.
Wozu muss ich mir das zwischenspeichern? Dann sag mir einfach deinen Prompt,
weil das ist das, wo die menschliche Kreativität reingegangen ist.
Und dann den Rest mache ich dann lokal selber.
Komm ein bisschen drauf an, aber prinzipiell stimme ich dir zu.
Einfach dieses Gefühl, okay, ich weiß, das ist jetzt generiert,
jetzt habe ich kein Interesse mehr, das zu lesen.
Also ich habe es auch schon in der Online-Community gehabt, wenn eine Person
halt wirklich quasi das, was sie schreiben wollte, nochmal ausformulieren hat
lassen, in so zwei Paragraphen Text von einer KI.
Das liest sich scheiße, das passt einfach nicht kontextuell hier rein.
Schreib doch einfach das, was du ursprünglich schreiben musst.
Und wenn es nur Stichpunkte sind, I don't care, ich will mit dir reden,
nicht mit deinem Filter.
Genau, was zu meinem allerersten von vor zwei Jahren noch bestehenden AI-Kommentar
führt, das war dieses Feature, das hat, glaube ich, Google vor zwei oder drei
Jahren vorgestellt, dass du in einer E-Mail sagen kannst, mach, ändere mal den Ton.
Das hat ja auch Apple Intelligence, Das sind eigentlich der sinnlosesten Features.
Vielleicht ist es sinnvoll, wenn du in einer Sprache dich unterhalten musst,
der du nicht 100% mächtig bist.
Es gibt für alle Use Cases auf jeden Fall. Aber wenn du jetzt sagst,
ich muss eine E-Mail schreiben an irgendwen, ich habe keinen Bock,
das auszuformulieren, ich schreibe drei Stichpunkte und dann macht er mir da
einen mehr absätzigen Text raus und den schicke ich weg.
Dann schickst du das über das Wire in einem größeren Format und auf der anderen
Seite hast du dann jemanden, der genau diesen Gedanken hat und sich denkt,
wozu muss ich diesen Scheiß überhaupt lesen? Das ist AI-Generäte, das sehe ich sofort.
Dann fragst du deine KI, dass du es wieder eindampfst in die drei Stichpunkte,
die die Person wahrscheinlich ursprünglich gebaut hat und somit hast du quasi ein,
inverses Kompressionsverfahren gebaut, wo du irgendwie kompakte Informationen
auf der einen Seite reinsteckst, das in ein... die...
Die Entropie davon erweiterst, das über den Ether transportierst und auf der
anderen Seite wieder eindampfst in die ursprünglichen Original...
Ja, aber die Entropie ist nicht wieder los.
Aber am Ende, vielleicht können wir ja irgendwann so eine Art Datenformat mitnutzen,
was den Ursprungstext versteckt mitschickt, damit man den zumindest noch zugänglich
hat und genauso lesen kann.
Also ein Thema, was noch AI adjacent ist, worüber ich mich gerne mal mit jemandem
unterhalten würde, der sich vielleicht damit auskennt, vielleicht finden wir
ja jemanden, wäre Markierung von AI Fake Images.
Weil es ja jetzt mehr und mehr so, also mittlerweile sind Videos und Bilder
ja wirklich gut genug, dass die schwer zu unterscheiden sind.
Es gibt Leute, die sagen, AI kann man ja Watermarks einbeimischen, da gibt es Verfahren.
Aber erstens gibt es halt schon bereits die ersten Verfahren,
diese Watermarks sauber wieder zu entfernen.
Und zweitens ist nicht garantiert, dass jemand, der irgendwie ein Bad Actor
ist und eine AI hat, irgendwie bei sich selbst gehostet oder ein
Nation State, der Fake News generiert, der wird natürlich keine Watermarks reinmachen.
Also müsstest du es eigentlich anders machen und jedwedes originäre Content-Material,
was weiß ich, eine Rede, ein Video von einer Rede vom Bundeskanzler,
das muss dann signiert sein, damit du da die Authentizität rückvollziehen kannst.
Du wissen kannst, okay, das ist irgendwie von von von Bundesregierung.de signiert.
Und nicht, dass du die AI zwingend ranzuschreiben, dass es AI ist,
weil das werden sie im Zweifelsfall nicht machen.
Ein sehr spannendes Feld, womit wir noch sehr viele Probleme in der Zukunft haben.
Ja, aber es ist auf jeden Fall ein Thema, was uns wahrscheinlich noch ein,
zweimal in der Zukunft beschäftigt. Ein, zweimal.
So CI-gegenwärtig habe ich es gefühlt.
Ist AI sowas wie Internet? Das ist kategorisch, so ist es auf der Ebene wie Internet.
Wir hatten irgendwie, in den 80ern hatten wir kein Internet und in den 90ern
hatten wir Internet und das ist dann plötzlich alles das, worüber wir geredet
haben und jetzt ist, in den 2010ern hatten wir keine AI und in den 2020ern haben
wir plötzlich AI und das reden alle nur noch über AI.
Naja, also es ist, also meine persönliche Vermutung und ich weiß nicht inwiefern,
dass hier irgendwie der Zukunft entspricht oder nicht, ist, dass die Büchse
der Pandora geöffnet ist. Es ist da, es ist here to stay auf jeden Fall.
Die Blase wird sich sicherlich ein bisschen verkleinern, also ich,
aber nicht komplett platzen im Sinne von, es geht weg.
Das kann ich mir nicht vorstellen, aber es wird definitiv kein Hype-Thema mehr
sein, aber es wird sicherlich auch, also kann ich mir auch nicht vorstellen,
dass es so sehr wieder in der Versenkung geschwindet, wie der ganze Blockchain-Scheiß.
Das meinst du, es gibt ja bestimmt Leute, die sagen, ach, das ganze AI-Taxe
wird sich nicht durchsetzen.
Ja, was heißt das, das wird sich nicht durchsetzen? Es ist da,
wie viele Leute nutzen es und es hat auch unglaublich viele sehr, sehr gute Use-Cases.
Aber was es momentan noch grundsätzlich vom Internet unterscheidet,
also kategorisch, ist, dass das Internet war so ein demokratisierender Faktor.
Das heißt, es gab schon von Anfang an, konntest du jeden Computer an jeden anderen
anschließen und du hast nicht viel gebraucht, um irgendwie ein.
Um irgendwie IP-Pakete hin und her zu schicken. Und die Anwendungen sind darauf gewachsen.
Und es ist eigentlich nachträglich passiert, dass es viele große Plattformen
gibt, die entstanden sind, die die Sachen zentralisiert haben.
Aber du kannst dich, wie du vorhin zum Beispiel mit Image oder so gezeigt hast,
du kannst dich von diesen Plattformen im Internet eigentlich immer noch wieder
lösen, indem du auf irgendeine Obsource-Variante setzt und dir nur was selber baust.
Das ist bei AI nicht so. Also bei AI gibt es Open-Source-Modelle,
aber eher so als Darreichung der großen Firmen, die zufällig ihre Modelle Open-Source
machen und eigentlich ist,
jemand hat mal in einem Vortrag AI mit einer Utility verglichen,
also Utility im Sinne von Wasser und Strom und Internet.
Internet als Anschluss und nicht als Feature, aber AI musst du quasi immer,
eigentlich, wenn du AI programmierst, sprichst du mit einer REST-API von einem
dieser N großen Anbieter.
Das liegt halt primär daran, dass da einfach leistungsfähigere Maschinen sind,
aber du hast schon recht, die großen Modelle, die die wirklich den meisten Wert
erzeugen aktuell, die sind nicht offen.
Und das ist ja sicherlich, weil da unglaubliche Millionen reinschließen.
Oder wenn sie offen sind, dann hast du nicht die Leistung, sie tatsächlich auch zu betreiben.
Sicherlich werden sich da in Zukunft Dinge ein bisschen mehr arrangieren,
in dem Sinne, dass es sicherlich noch leistungsfähigere Modelle geben wird,
die wir noch weniger zu Hause betreiben können.
Aber dass die Sachen, die heute als die High-End-Sachen zählen,
vielleicht in Zukunft auch hinreicht gut genug sind, dass du sie lokal betreiben kannst. Vielleicht.
Sicherlich. Also sicherlich wird sie in der Hinsicht ein bisschen demokratizieren.
Das wird nichts daran ändern, dass... Du brauchst aber noch diese Massen an
Rechenpower, um überhaupt eins zu bootstrappen zum Beispiel.
Klar, und das ist halt... Aber du hast natürlich auch nicht die Möglichkeit
gehabt, vielleicht kann man es mit sowas wie Krypto vergleichen.
Krypto im Sinne von Währung oder Krypto im Sinne von Verbrannter Begriff, Kryptografie.
Es gab am Anfang nirgendwo verschlüsselte Verbindungen,
weil sowas wie ein Verschlüsselungsalgorithmus halt gehütet wurde.
Teuer und geschützt und man musste es auf Papier niedergeschrieben in Buchform
aus den USA raustragen, um es in Europa benutzen zu dürfen.
Vielleicht.
Vielleicht dauert es einfach noch eine Weile bis, und jetzt hast du nicht die,
Möglichkeit, das selber zu machen, sondern du musstest das benutzen,
und du musstest es irgendwie in der Lage sein, selber zu implementieren,
und was jetzt noch halt schwierig ist, du bootstrappst nicht mal eben dein eigenes
Foundation-Model, weil du gar nicht an die,
Trainings-Korpus rankommst, das heißt, es ist schon so ein bisschen so ein Henne-Ei-Problem,
du brauchst halt noch erstmal ein anderes LLM, was du vielleicht nicht selber
entwickelt hast, und so weiter.
Trainingsdaten sind ja auch ein massives Problem in dieser Welt,
also in der AI-Welt und wie man an die rankommt, also wie sie gesammelt werden,
das würde ich aber auch mal in die nächste Folge verschieben.
Ja, das ist definitiv ein Problem, was uns noch ein, zwei Mal in der Zukunft
beschäftigen wird und das war eigentlich der Bogen, den ich vorhin schon spannen
wollte, bevor wir uns wieder verrannt haben mit dem Thema.
Lass uns doch mal über was anderes reden. Du hattest vorhin schon mal ganz kurz
angeteasert, dass du Z-Nutzer bist.
Ähm, genau. Also jetzt nicht verwechseln. Du hattest mir mal gezeigt,
diese Icons sind auch alle super ähnlich.
Also Zen und Zed. Und was war das dritte? Äh, weiß ich gar nicht mehr.
Ich möchte behaupten, was so Icon-Kreativität angeht, ist in den letzten Jahren
einiges vorlort. Sorry, dass ich nochmal ganz kurz zur AI komme.
Da gab es einen wunderbaren Blogpost, der hat einfach nur die ganzen AI-Icons.
Die sehen aus wie Buttholes.
Also ob das jetzt Gemini, ob das Apple in Talent ist, ob das Clown ist,
ob das Open AI ist. Aber alle Icons sehen aus wie Buttholes.
Das Chrom-Logo sieht aus wie ein Butthole. Das Slack-Logo ist irgendein.
Das Slack-Logo ist irgendein Kringel. Es gibt ganz viele Logos,
die einfach so ein swirliger, regenbogenfarbiger Kringel sind.
Das sind alles diese Möchte-Gern-Alles-Apps. Alles.
Kreise sind halt populär. Guck dir allein das IMMIG-Logo an.
Sorry, aber das IMMIG-Logo ist auch eine Mischung aus einer Aperture und einer
Blume in Regenbogenfarben.
Jedes Logo ist ein Butthor. Es geht nicht anders.
Okay, jetzt suchen wir bitte das Anthropik-Logo von Cloud raus.
Cloud ist definitiv... Das ist sehr Butthor. Das sieht schon sehr nach Katze von hinten aus.
Okay. Ja, was du aber gesagt hast, ist das Icon von Zen und Zed,
die sind sich sehr ähnlich.
Wir packen das in die Show Notes. Und das sind zwei Apps, die auch einen sehr,
sehr ähnlichen Namen haben, aber überhaupt nichts miteinander zu tun haben.
Zen ist mein Browser der Wahl und Zed ist... Zed ist mein neuer Editor der Wahl.
Aber eigentlich sind sie philosophisch schon verwandt, denn sie machen eigentlich
das, was es schon gibt, nochmal. Im Sinne...
Im Sinne von Zen machen sie einen neuen Browser, aber auf einer alten Basis,
das heißt also auf Basis von Firefox oder
Arc, einen neuen Browser auf der Basis von Chrome. Mium.
Z ist ein Editor, wenn ich dir den zeige, und ich hab dir den ja schon gezeigt.
Ich hab's ja auch schon benutzt, ja. Du hast es auch schon benutzt und wir haben
es auch schon zum gemeinsamen Meditieren benutzt, aber wenn ich dir das jetzt
so zeigen würde, dann würdest du im ersten Moment erstmal denken,
Naja, es sieht genauso aus wie VSCode.
Es ist relativ minimalistischer.
Es ist so sehr wie VSCode, wie halt ein Texteditor aussieht.
Du hast einen Filebrowser, du hast ein Editor-Fenster und hast ein integriertes Terminal.
So, warum zum Gaia switcht man jetzt von VSCode, was ich seit zehn Jahren benutze
und was mittlerweile alles kann?
Literally alles. Und VSCode ist mittlerweile so eine grundlegende Technologie.
Also ich weiß noch, als ich angefangen habe zu arbeiten professionell,
da war ich der Einzige, der VSCode verwendet hat.
Und alle anderen haben noch Visual Studio verwendet oder und so weiter und so
fort, weil ja die IDE quasi, ich habe mich auch gefragt, warum,
wenn ich programmiere, muss ich ja diesen IDE-Editor benutzen,
weil da ja der Compiler drin ist.
Ja, man benutzt Visual Studio für Windows-Entwicklung, man benutzt PyStorm für
Python-Entwicklung, man benutzt Xcode auf macOS und so weiter und man ist dann
immer, weil man dafür entwickelt,
gezwungen diesen Editor zu verwenden, weil er natürlich auch volle Integration hat,
Und weil er alle Features bietet, die man zum Entwickeln braucht,
ist ein Integrated Development Environment und nicht in erster Linie ein Editor.
Wenn man, wie ich, sich irgendwann mal in den Kopf gesetzt hat,
Vim zu lernen und dann leider sehr physisch davon abhängig geworden ist,
Vim benutzen zu können, ist man leider so ein bisschen gefickt.
Wenn man einen Editor benutzen muss, der keinen Vim kann, weil dann fühlt es
sich an, als würde man irgendwie zwei Meter hinterm Schreibtischstuhl von hinten
mit langen Besenstielen auf der Tastatur den Computer bedienen müssen.
Du brauchst Wim-Bindings im Editor. Wenn Wim-Bindings nicht gehen.
Dann fühlt es sich an, als wäre man betrunken.
Alles ist langsamer, man macht Fehler, es geht nicht gut.
Und das hatte VS Code gekonnt und VS Code hat es relativ okay gekonnt.
Es hatte ganz okay Wim-Bindings mit den Add-ons.
VS Code hat einen Debugger und VS Code hat mittlerweile, VS Code hat dieses
Language-Server-Protokoll-Konzept durchgetreten.
Und ich muss sagen, dieses Language-Server-Protokoll-Dings war eigentlich so ein Dammbruch.
Auf jeden Fall. Weil es die IDE vom Editor gelöst hat.
Plötzlich kannst du einen neuen Editor
bauen, ohne dass du diese ganzen Sprachfeatures implementieren musst.
Was zum Beispiel eine Geschichte, die ich eventuell schon mal,
ich benutze jetzt nicht unsere Volltextsuche, die ich eventuell schon mal erwähnt
habe, ist, dass Visual Studio eigentlich mehrere C++ Compiler beinhaltet.
Es hat nämlich den MSVC zum Kompilieren benutzt, es hat aber für alle möglichen
In-Editor Sprachanalyse-Features einen Intel C++ oder C-Compiler verwendet,
der separat gelaufen ist und es.
Konnte dadurch passieren, dass du Fehler angezeigt bekommen hast,
die dann beim Kompilieren nicht aufgetreten sind, gerade wenn du zwischen mehr
unterschiedlichen C++ Versionen hin und her gewechselt.
Bis beim neueren war eventuell der eine schon weiter als der andere. Anyway,
VS Code ist eigentlich mittlerweile diese, so eine grundlegende Technologie,
die mittlerweile jeder benutzt und sie ist so grundlegend geworden,
dass mittlerweile ist es eigentlich so das Chromium der Editors,
weil mittlerweile gibt es Forks von VS Code, weil die Leute sich denken,
das eigentliche Feature ist nicht mehr der Editor.
VS Code erschlägt alles und kann alles.
Das Feature, was wir jetzt bauen wollen, ist die Agentic AI Programming.
Ich verspreche, ich werde jetzt nicht über AI reden.
Aber mittlerweile ist der Editor gut genug, dass du sagen kannst,
ich forge den jetzt, der bringt mir eh alles mit und ich baue das eine Feature,
was ich bauen will, AI, baue ich da rein. Wie heißen sie? Zählen sie mal auf.
Cursor, Windsurf, wie heißt das Ding von Amazon? Vergessen, egal.
Es gibt mindestens vier oder fünf Forks von VS Code.
Es gibt ja schon ewig viele Forks von VS Code. Also Forks sind ja per se von
dem Ding keine neue Idee. Es gibt ja auch schon ewig VS Code.
Genau. Es ist ja, es ist eine krass... Es ist mittlerweile so schlimm geworden,
dass Microsoft sogar rechtlich gegen einige dieser Forks vorgeht oder Firmen,
die diese Forks betreiben, sogar für ganz viel Geld von OpenAI gekauft werden.
Anyway, ich wollte eigentlich nicht über VS Code reden, aber Warum sollte man
heutzutage nochmal einen neuen Editor bauen? Mhm.
Gibt ja schon alles. Die logische Antwort ist, weil man kann.
Und weil man kann und weil man will. Ich glaube, die Leute, die Z bauen, Z ist kein VS Code Fork.
Z ist ein komplett nativer from scratch gebauter Editor.
Gibt es auch noch ein paar. Es gibt noch Rust-basierte Editor Labs.
Es gibt Helix. Die kann ich mal in die Show-Notes suchen. Helix ist ja jetzt
quasi auch ein CLI-only Editor.
Also im Sinn, was du jetzt nicht mit UI im Fenster aufmachst und was in deinen
US auf die Art und Weise läuft.
Labs sieht auch fast vollständig aus wie so ein VS Code Fork.
Ist auch sehr umfangreich, ist allerdings nicht so aktiv in den Köln.
Also LAPCE, wir packen es nämlich schon. Genau.
Und Z ist from scratch native in Rust gebaut. Natürlich. Was auch sonst?
Das ist nicht der Grund, warum ich es benutze. Das ist nur der Grund,
warum ich in der Lage war, ein paar Sachen zu fixen, die mich daran gestört haben.
Bevor du weitergehst in Architur oder was auch immer, hat das irgendwas zu tun,
wenn ich an Rust Editor denke, ist mein erster Gedanke immer,
was dieser eine Typ damals gebaut hat mit diesem Rope-Based Kram,
ist das irgendwie daraus hervorgegangen mit oder hat das überhaupt nichts damit zu tun?
Es ist ein Konzept, was hier mit drin ist. Cool, okay.
Aber es enthält keinen Code aus vorherigen,
es geht diesen diesen sei editor gab es ja ja also es gab es ist generation
zwei oder drei von weiterentwicklung set ist losgetreten worden von den leuten
die vorher atom gebaut nach was und das wusste ich nicht genau da gibt es auch
ein zwei podcasts mit als interview mit,
dem mit dem originalentwickler die die super spannend waren in,
ich fasse es kurz zusammen, der Typ wollte halt damals einen guten Editor bauen
und es war am einfachsten mit Electron.
Ja, die haben Electron quasi gebaut, um einen Editor zu bauen.
Oder es war am einfachsten mit Webtechnologien in Chrom und deswegen haben sie sich für Electron,
ne Quatsch, deswegen haben sie für Atom, den Entwickler, den Editor,
den sie gebaut haben, eine Shell gebaut.
Was ist die Shell um einen Atom drum herum? Das sind Elektronen. Ja, das ist wunderbar.
Vorher hieß es Atom Shell, dann hieß es Elektron.
Und Atom gibt es mittlerweile nicht mehr, weil es einen zweiten Editor gab,
der architektonisch ähnlich war, aber von einer größeren Firma vorangetrieben
wurde. Das war Viers Code.
Eigentlich ist es dasselbe wie Atom, nochmal neu und mit mehr Geld dahinter.
Nicht Elektron, aber sehr ähnlich.
Und es ist ursprünglich Elektron-basiert gewesen. Ich glaube,
sie hatten auch angefangen damit, aber ich benutze jetzt aktuell ein eigener
Hintergrund. Aber es ist, du kannst in Viers Code kannst du die Chrome Dev-Tools
anmachen und Viers Code live damit debuggen und die meisten Add-ons,
eigentlich alle Add-ons sind in C++ geschrieben.
Und alle Add-ons sind in JavaScript geschrieben.
Und an manchen Stellen, ich glaube, das Terminal in VSCode ist mittlerweile
Canvas-basiert, weil es performanter ist als ein HTML-gerendertes Terminal.
Aber die haben halt alle die gleichen Einschränkungen.
Und der Hintergrund von den Z-Leuten war, zehn Jahre später nach Atom.
Wir wollen es nochmal wissen, VS Code benutzen wir jeden Tag,
aber es ist nicht schnell genug.
Und der Typ, der ursprünglich Atom gemacht hat, ist eigentlich auch aktiver
Vim-Nutzer und ihm haben die VS Code, die Vim-Nutzer, die Vim-Nutzer, die Vim-Nutzer,
Und ihnen haben die WIM-Integration in VS Code auch nicht gereicht.
Das habe ich auch gemerkt.
Wenn du WIM benutzt, ein paar Sachen funktionieren in VS Code einfach nicht gut genug.
Folding. Da muss man irgendwelche Hack-Checkboxen in den Settings anmachen,
damit du, wenn du einen Codeblock zusammengefaltet hast und du gehst mit dem
Cursor runter, runter, runter, runter,
dann geht der in den zusammengefalteten trotzdem in den Gefalteten rein und
faltet es wieder auf. Hat WIM nicht gemacht.
Die Z-Leute haben sich gesagt, wir bauen jetzt einen Performanten-Editor.
Dazu haben sie erstmal ein eigenes UI-Framework gebaut, das heißt GPU-Ui,
also ein GPU-basiertes UI-Framework, was so schnell rendert wie eine Game Engine.
Es gibt Demos, wo sie irgendwie Tabs mit 120 Hertz switchen.
Sehr schön. Und dazu mussten sie die Tastatureingaben von Mac schneller machen.
Was? Wenn ich jetzt Command-Tab drücke oder Steuerung-Tab, um die Tabs zu switchen,
dann ist die Geschwindigkeit davon beschränkt durch das Delay der Eingabe meiner
Tastatur, das musst du in Mac
erst hochsetzen. Wie, das musst du hochsetzen, da kannst du nicht drin.
Wenn ich jetzt hier an der Zeile bin und einfach den rechten Cursor drücke und
da geht das, das geht nicht schneller, das muss man in Mac, das muss ich irgendein
Hack einstellen, dass der schneller, dass du schnellere Iterationen,
Zeichenabfragen kriegst, wenn du eine Taste hältst. Okay, wild.
Hätte ich nicht gedacht, dass man da irgendwie reingrätschen kann,
aber... Das macht Zett nicht, das hat er für eine Demo in seinem System Gang hat. Ach so, ah, okay.
Es ist ein GPU-basiertes UI-Framework. Der Editor ist von vorne selber gebaut.
Den entwickeln sie seit drei, vier Jahren. Sie sind erst seit zwei Jahren oder so Open Source.
Es ist alles GPL.
Krass, stark. Es steckt eine Firma dahinter, die Funding hat.
Wie die? Z-Industries. Wie haben die Sponsoren, die das Das weiß ich nicht genau.
Du kannst den... Ist wahrscheinlich auch gut dokumentiert. Es ist auf deren
Seite wahrscheinlich gut zu finden. Hat mich bislang nicht so sehr interessiert.
Und dann haben sie einen Editor gebaut, der in erster Linie erstmal so aussieht
wie VS Code. Also sie haben nicht diese große Iconbar an der Seite.
Und er hat erst... Also ich benutze ihn seit einem Jahr. Er hat erst seit wenigen
Monaten einen Debugger.
Ja, stimmt. Ich erinnere mich. Er hat aber schon relativ lange Collaborative
Editing gehabt, was eines der Hauptfeatures war, was sie haben wollten.
Das fand ich weird, dass das gleich so ein Fokus mit an war,
dass du halt alle Leute nicht verbinden konntest.
Kurz bevor alle über AI geredet haben.
Haben die halt sich gesagt, wir wollen gemeinsam an Code arbeiten und deswegen
möchtest du Live-Sharing-Sessions,
haben, wo du von 10 Leuten die Cursor auf einer Datei haben kannst und um natürlich
den State einer Textdatei über mehrere Clients zu verteilen,
musst du in der Lage sein, die Datenrepräsentation deiner Datei,
zu synchronisieren und dazu benutzen sie diese, das machen sie unter der Haube
mit Rope-Datenstrukturen und mit einer bestimmten Buffer-Technik,
auf die ich jetzt nicht ins Detail eingehen würde.
Aber ich meine, mal naiv, wenn ich einen Editor baue und ich baue hier diesen
einfachen Buffer, wir haben alle mal so einen kleinen Text-Buffer irgendwo gebaut,
um irgendwo was hinzurindern,
diese 500 Zeilen Textdatei, die ich dir zeige, ist im Memory von diesem Editor
nicht repräsentiert als ein zusammenhängender String.
Das lernt man sehr schnell, dass das scheißkomplex ist.
Wenn ich irgendwo in der Mitte ein Zeichen hinzufüge, muss er plötzlich alle
Zeichen, die danach kommen, einmal nach rechts schieben.
Ja, das macht man anders. Und er muss ein Modell haben, das irgendwie auf Zeichen
so und so bis Zeichen so und so ist ein Symbol, nämlich ein Keyword.
Das muss ich so highlighten.
Das heißt, man muss eine sehr komplexe Datenstruktur intern repräsentieren und
das kriegen sie ganz gut hin.
Und dann lade mal eine Gigabyte-Logdatei in den Editor rein.
Genau, oder mach das mal.
Was sie sehr gut machen hier drin, also es ist wirklich ein sauschneller Editor,
Das kann ich leider auf Arbeit gar nicht so richtig wertschätzen,
weil dort haben wir so ein Multiscreen-Setup,
wo alles nochmal Video gerendert wird, weil es ist egal.
Auf dem nativen Bildschirm von einem guten Laptop, zum Beispiel so einem MacBook,
sieht das richtig, richtig flott aus.
Kollaboratives Editieren würde ich eher häufiger benutzen, aber wenn dann auf
Arbeit und da denke ich, dürfen wir nicht deren Infrastruktur mit unserem Code füttern. Achso, ja, ja.
Die Frage, wie die die Verbindung aufmachen, aber ich will ja fast daran ausgehen,
dass sie das... Aber diese Architektur, die sie dafür gebaut haben,
für Collaborative Editing, enablt aber auch halt andere geile Features.
Zum Beispiel, ich zeig dir jetzt mal kurz, wenn ich jetzt nach einem Begriff
suche, ich nehme mal einen sehr
banalen Struct und ich ändere mal das Syntaxial Editing auf es hell ist,
dann siehst du, die Suche geht nicht in der Sidebar auf, sondern ich habe einen
Tab gekriegt mit der Suche und darin habe ich jetzt hier so faltbare,
die heißen Multibuffers, das heißt, ich habe einen Tab, wo alle und unter Headings die einzelnen.
Einzelnen Treffer auftauchen. Das sieht so ein bisschen aus wie so ein GitHub-Diff-View
und in den Diffs in dem Git-Tool kannst du das auch verwenden.
Ich kann hier noch rauszoomen und das größer machen und wenn sich irgendwann
zwei solche Bereiche überschneiden, dann werden sie hier gemerged.
Das ist jetzt hier so ein Multi-Buffer. Was den geilen Effekt hat,
ist, wenn ich nach diesem Begriff suche, kann ich jetzt irgendwie im ganzen
Dings nach einem Wort suchen,
und dann kann ich Also das in der Ansicht hätte ich gerne in deiner Podcastsuche.
Ja, genau, genau. Das können wir machen, pass auf. Ich habe das Projekt,
das ist jetzt nicht super, aber anyway, dafür ist es super praktisch.
Du kannst jetzt, also hast du ein Editor, wo du für jeden Treffer so die paar
Zeilen davor und ein paar Zeilen danach hast und du könntest jetzt da drin zum
Beispiel direkt in allen Dateien, wo du dieses Wort vorkommend gleichzeitig editieren. Super cool.
Ein Feature, was wir auch haben, ist natürlich AI.
Du hast hier so ein Editor, so ein AI-Agent an der Seite. Haben sie aber auch
gesagt, dass sie sich auch komplett desablen lässt, nur um das hinzuzufügen.
In der nächsten Version, die wahrscheinlich herausgekommen ist,
wenn ihr diese Folge hört, gibt es einen Settings-Flag, wo man die gesamte AI wieder ausmachen kann.
Aber es ist zum Beispiel eine der Sachen, womit sich so ein Editor-Firma sehr
gut monetarisieren lässt. Viele Leute wollen sowas ja auch im Ältesten haben.
Du kannst für 20 Euro im Monat kannst du Zed Pro abonnieren,
dann hast du deren AI-Backend.
Die haben ein relativ gutes Predictive Editing-Model. Das finde ich ganz schick.
Du machst eine Änderung hier und dann geht ein Cursor an. Wenn ich dann Option
drücke, kann ich tap, tap, tap die, springt der direkt zur nächsten Stelle.
Ich bin auch sehr gewöhnt dran an sowas.
Das ist was, was Vias Code auch
macht. Ich finde, in Zed funktioniert es besser. Das ist ja ein Cursor.
Also das ist so,
Um nochmal den Bogen zurückzuschlagen, VS Code hat sehr viel Features zu Commodity-Features
gemacht, die man relativ gut in sein eigenes einbauen kann.
Oder Language-Server ist eine so eine Sache.
Z benutzt für seinen Debugger eigentlich auch bloß ein View und unten drunter
laufen Debugging-Plugins, die ursprünglich teilweise von VS Code kommen.
Ein Kritikpunkt ist zum Beispiel, ich habe jetzt hier Language-Server-Support
für TypeScript. Was macht es da?
Der TypeScript-Language-Server ist eine TypeScript-Anwendung selber,
das heißt Z launcht mir ein Node.js under the hood, mit dem es dann kommuniziert. Das ist wunderbar.
Ich würde auch sagen, die meisten Language-Server sind sicherlich self-hosted.
Genau, also was muss der Editor mitbringen? Einen guten Editor.
Genau dieses Multi-Buffer-Editing hier ist halt so ein Beispiel dafür.
Es muss halt flott sein und muss halt Schnittstellen für einen.
Language-Server mitbringen. Es bringt Schnittstellen für Agenting Editing mit.
Das heißt, ich kann meiner AI Zugriff auf Tools geben, auf irgendwelche MCPs,
auf irgendwelche MCPs-Server. Und so weiter und so fort.
Und was in Z cool ist, du kannst hier die Themes switchen.
Ich finde auch cool, dass sie direkt so ein... Ich sehe es in der Nutzung schon
quasi diesen, wie nennt man das, diesen Multibar, diese Quadratmeter.
Du hast einen Tesserturkürzel, du hast so ein Textfeld, wo du Es bedient sich komplett.
Also ein abschreckendes Ding, warum man von seinem Haupttool zu einem anderen
Tool nicht wechseln möchte, ist, weil sie es anders bedient.
Z bedient sich komplett wie VS Code.
Du hast dieses Command-P, du hast Command-Shift-P. Es ist an sich genau dasselbe
Ding. Ich finde das mittlerweile in fast jeder App.
Ich finde es gut, dass man in der Chat-App das hat. Ich finde es gut,
dass man für meinen Git-Client sowas kann.
Ich finde es gut, dass natürlich mein Editor sowas drin hat.
Im Browser genauso. Also ich finde mittlerweile sollte es eine primitive sein,
genauso wie dass jede App irgendwie diese Menübar hier oben populiert mit Datei
bearbeiten und schließen.
Am besten sollte es gleich noch im System sein. Ich meine, ich nutze ja auch
Raycast Systemwide, was quasi genau das ist.
Ist das nicht sogar das, was irgendwie mit dem nächsten Mac OS kommt?
Lass uns das jetzt an dieser Stelle auslassen.
Was cool ist an Zed, um das letzte sozusagen, das ist derselbe Shortcut wie
bei VS Code, um das Colorscheme zu wechseln.
Da komme ich hier in die Theme-Auswahl. Ich ändere das nie.
Ich ändere das dreimal am Tag. Oh, Nanowise, Light ist ja geil. Ja, siehst du?
Jetzt Pink. Ich liebe Pinky. Ein Feature, was bei Z schön ist,
ich kann hier eingeben, das ist Fuzzy Search auf den Themes,
ich gebe ein Light. Immer Fuzzy Search.
Alles Fuzzy Search. Alles Fuzzy Search. Und jetzt kann ich hier hoch und runter
gehen, ich wähle eins aus und wenn ich jetzt hier etwas ändere und ein Buchstaben,
dann kann ich zum nächsten gehen und die Suche bleibt stabil. Ich weiß, wo du hinst.
Die Besucher bleibt stabil, wenn ich hoch und runter gehe. Das hab ich gefixt.
Vorher hast du, wenn ich Light eingegeben habe und das T wieder gelöscht habe,
hat er von vorne in der Liste gesucht und mir wieder den ersten Treffer für
Light gegeben oder für Lai ohne T.
Und dann ist natürlich das gesamte Theme vom Editor sofort weggeswitcht.
Hat mich genervt. Das ist geil. Du hast Commits da reinbekommen. Finde ich mega.
So, das war mein Break of the Week.
Ne, also falls ihr mal Bock habt einen neuen Editor auszuprobieren und nicht
an irgendwie IDEs gebunden seid,
wie Xcode oder Visual Studio man kann definitiv damit auch TypeScript und C++
und Swift entwickeln und auch Go und Rust hab ich alles damit schon gemacht,
probiert's mal aus, gibt's für macOS und Linux und irgendwann demnächst auch für Windows.
So, das klang jetzt schon verdächtig nach einem Pick. Ich nenne das jetzt einfach
mal meinen ersten Pick. Den 0. Pick, ja.
Hast du einen Pick? Ja, ich habe ein paar Sachen mitgebracht.
Ich nehme auch mal noch einen 0. Pick mit rein, weil ich es gerade noch in der
Liste sehe, weil du es vorher schon aufgeschrieben hast, und zwar Talescale.
Ist Software, die ich seit noch nicht allzu langer Zeit nutze,
jetzt vielleicht ein dreiviertel Jahr oder so, wenn ich versuche,
mich da zurück zu erinnern, ist es unglaublich toller Mehrwert, den es mir bietet.
Haben wir noch nicht im Podcast erwähnt. Ich habe es gerade mit Ripgrab in den
Dateien gesucht. Sehr gut, sehr gut.
Die wirkliche Fulltexture. Die besser funktionierende Fulltexture.
Es ist an sich, habe ich vorhin schon erwähnt, quasi ein Tool,
was es mir ermöglicht, dass ich alle meine Geräte in ein, also von der Idee
her, zusammen mit einem VPN hänge.
Under the Hood nutzt Tailscale auch nur WireGuard, also bestehende Technologien.
Aber es macht halt ein Frontend dafür, was es benutzt. Es macht nicht viel Frontend,
es gibt Apps für jede Plattform und ich kann meine Geräte miteinander netzwerken lassen.
Und das ist ganz fantastisch, weil ich halt meine Geräte, die haben alle Hostnames,
ich kann einfach von meinem Mac hier, von meinem Laptop, meinen Homeserver anpengen,
der hat seinen Namen, ich kann auf diversen Ports zugreifen,
was da auch immer läuft, ich kann mich einfach drauf, ich kann das nicht einfach ansprechen.
Ich kann auch manche Geräte sozusagen Exit-Node deklarieren.
Zum Beispiel gibt es eine Tayscale-App, auch beim Apple TV zu Hause.
Der Apple TV hat immer Strom, der hängt am Kabel. Das ist eine Exit-Node,
die ich nutzen kann, um einen ganzen Traffic einfach dann durch mein Handnetzwerk zu schleifen.
Und es gibt die Möglichkeit, auf einem Apple TV eine Apple zu installieren,
die genügend Netzwerkprotokoll Berechtigung hat, um als Exit-Node für was anderes
zu funktionieren? Erstaunlicherweise ja.
Die braucht nur VPN-Profile. Dazu nutzen die sie im Hintergrund.
Dafür gibt TVOS auch alles frei.
Und da kannst du das eben nutzen. Das ist unglaublich cool. Du kannst auch über Tailscale,
sowas nutzen wie Custom-DNS, was du da reinfuhrst noch und dann kannst du auch
sagen, dass all deine Geräte quasi in deinem Tail-Net, so heißt das typischerweise,
die da zusammenhängen, auch noch durch dieses DNS mit entfuhrst bekommen und
da kann ich dann zum Beispiel Adblocking noch mit draufwerfen und hab dann
zum Beispiel witzigerweise auf Android kannst du die meisten Apps Werbescheiße
verbieten, indem du einfach noch Adblocking auf DNS-Ebene machst und dann passiert
das einfach nicht. Ist auch unglaublicher Mehrwert.
Und es kann halt so coole Sachen wie Tail Drop, was ich vorhin schon erwähnt habe.
Es gibt noch so viele Namen als Tail Drive, wo du Pfade in deinem Tail Net mounten
kannst. Und ist das jetzt was, wofür du Geld bezahlst?
An sich, Tail Scale ist eine Firma, die verdienen Geld. Du kannst es privat
kostenlos nutzen mit bis zu 100 Geräten in deinem Tail Net.
Das wird langsam knapp bei dir, oder? Das deckt die meisten privaten Use Cases komplett ab.
Was ich saucool von Tail Scale finde, ist, dass es gab eine Open Source Implementierung
von Tail Scale. Die hieß Headscale.
Und was die Tailscale-Leute gemacht haben, ist, die haben nicht einfach,
wie manche andere Firmen, ignoriert, dass es das gibt oder was dagegen sogar
noch getan, dass es das gibt, sondern die haben den Typen, der das gemacht hat,
eingestellt und haben ihn weiter Headscale entwickeln lassen.
Und jetzt hast du in allen Tailscale-Clients kannst du sagen,
du möchtest nicht den offiziellen Tailscale, also du brauchst deren Infra,
deren Server eigentlich auch nur, damit deine Geräte sich überhaupt initial
finden können. Danach läuft ja eh alles Peer-to-Peer.
Es ist ja genau das.
Derp, das Protokoll? Nee, ich glaube, egal, da kenne ich mich nicht mehr im
Detail aus, aber du kannst auch in allen Tayscale-Clients sagen,
du möchtest gerne nicht Official-Tayscale nutzen, sondern Headscale und kannst
dein eigenes Backend dafür hosten.
Und dann hast du das am Laufen. Das ist fantastisch, das ist toll, dass sie das machen.
Headscales-Backend wird nach wie vor supported, wird weiterhin weiterentwickelt,
aber es ist halt einfach nur eine Möglichkeit und es existiert neben Tayscale zusätzlich mit.
Ist top, ist wunderbare Software, kann ich wärmstens empfehlen,
einfach mal auszuprobieren, weil es so viel was mich zu meinem nächsten Pick
gleich mit drüberbringt. Oh, noch ein Pick.
Und zwar habe ich ja vorhin gesagt, dass ich viele Sachen auf meinem Homeserver
hoste. Was ich aber nicht so lange habe,
nicht machen möchte, ist, und was ich früher gemacht habe, und was so der typische
Weg ist, wenn du Sachen zu Hause laufen hast, die aber nach außen hin zugänglich
machen möchtest, ist, dass du irgendwie eine Portfreigabe machst.
Und das ist eklig.
Ich möchte nicht, das möchte ich auch nie wieder machen müssen.
Das ist zum einen frickelig zu konfigurieren, und zum anderen will ich nicht,
dass überhaupt Sachen in meinem Router nach außen freigegeben sind,
also direkt Ports komplett freigegeben sind. Du möchtest eigentlich immer ein VPN haben.
Du möchtest ein VPN haben, und du musstest dann ja noch so etwas um so was wie DynDNS kümmern.
Wenn, sag mal, du willst den Use Case ermöglichen, dass du so ein Image zum
Beispiel zu Hause hostest und anderen Leuten Zugriff auf so ein Shared-Album-Link
oder so, gibt es, dass sie Fotos anschauen können oder vielleicht sogar was
hochladen können in ein Album, da musst du es halt irgendwie zugänglich machen.
Das heißt, du brauchst irgendwie ein DynDNS, damit die deinen Router finden
können und auf dem Port so und so dann durchgefordert werden zu deinem Image,
was zu Hause in deinem Heimnetzwerk läuft.
Eine Möglichkeit, das zu umgehen, ist natürlich sowas wie Tayscale zu nutzen.
Das teilst du aber typischerweise nicht mit anderen. Das würde ich gerade fragen.
Gibt es etwa bei Tayscale ein Feature, dass du irgendwie so einen Ephemeral-Zugang
jemandem geben kannst, der, was weiß ich, ich gebe dir Zugriff auf meinen Raspberry
Pi für 10 Stunden und dann verfällt dieser Zugang? Genau das kannst du machen.
Also es gibt, ich verbringe die mal durcheinander, es gibt genau zwei Features,
Tailscale-Serve und Tailscale-Funnel.
Das eine ist das, das andere ist quasi ein bisschen persistenter.
Was du dadurch nicht machen möchtest, ist, die haben in ihrer Doku geschrieben,
das geht, aber dadurch, dass es ja durch deren Server geht, gibt es Bandwidth-Limits,
die sagen dir nicht genau, was die sind, Die halten sich vor,
einfach wahrscheinlich zu sagen, hey, du schiebst da gerade einen Terabyte drüber.
Nee, ist nicht. Aber du musst dich doch nicht über deren Server dafür tunneln, oder?
Naja, wenn du halt über eine Domain gehst, bei denen, dann musst du halt irgendwie...
Boah, nee, ich weiß es nicht genau.
Da weiß ich so wenig über Netzwerkarchitektur, wie sowas funktioniert.
Aber zumindest, ja, das gibt es als Feature.
Du könntest auch, du kannst sowas wie, du sagst, auch krasse Möglichkeiten,
solche Access Control Levels zu definen.
Du kannst dich auch mit jemandem anders zusammenhängen, dass die Person auch
einen Tail-Scale-Account hat, ein eigenes Tail-Net und du bestimmte Devices sharest quasi dadurch.
Das geht auch. Nutze ich aber jetzt persönlich nicht.
Aber das wäre zumindest eine Möglichkeit, wie du sowas ermöglichst,
dass du halt Zugang zu den Geräten über dein Tail-Net ermöglichst.
Was andere Leute machen, ist, dass sie das ein bisschen manueller machen.
Das geht natürlich vor allem, wenn du technisch versiert Freunde slash Familie
hast, dass du den WireGuard-Config gibst zum Beispiel, damit sie in dein Netzwerk
reinkommen und somit das geht.
Was ich aber sehr, sehr cool finde und was ich letztens entdeckt habe und was für mich,
Unglaublich tolle, fantastische Software ist ein Tool namens Pangolin.
Das habe ich installiert auf einem kleinen VPS, einfach bei Head-by-Heads nachgeklickt,
so eine 3-Euro-Maschine und da läuft nichts drauf außer Pangolin.
Und das Ding ist ansprechbar unter Subdomain X auf meiner Domain.
Und Pangolin macht nichts anderes als den Tunnel zu bestimmten anderen Geräten
aufzumachen und quasi intern noch einen Traffic mitzumanagen,
damit es Domains freigibt und über diese Domains bestimmte Ports anspricht auf anderen Geräten.
Du kannst in... Also in eine Reverse Proxy. Ja, genau. Das ist ein Salesforce-Reverse Proxy.
Und das Coole ist, das wusste ich einfach, ich hatte gehofft,
dass es geht, Pangolin selber konfiguriert sich entweder über WireGuard oder
über, da gibt es ein Tool, was sie glaube ich selber geschrieben haben,
und dann muss Gerbil, wenn mir nicht alles täuscht, was aber andere heute auch nur WireGuard nutzt.
Und kannst du quasi zu einer Site, was in dem Fall so etwas mit deinem Heimnetzwerk
ist, einen Tunnel aufmachen und da drin dann Geräte ansprechen,
die in deinem Heimnetzwerk verfügbar sind.
Was aber auch geht, und das finde ich großartig, weil dieser VPS für mich einfach
ein Teil von meinem Telnet ist, ist, dass ich einfach sage, hey Pangolin,
wenn mich jemand anspricht auf, sage ich mal, ich möchte jetzt hier nicht im
Podcast live sagen, aber mich spricht jemand an auf SharePoint.
Schick mir doch mal bitte die letzte Akronomisierbar-Folge, damit ich sie bearbeiten kann.
Dann gebe ich den Link auf share.meiner-Domain und das vorwortet von Pangolin
durch mein Tailnet zu meinem Home-Server, wo dann, keine Ahnung,
Nextcloud läuft und das kannst du dann eben direkt so ansprechen.
Für dich ist es eine Domain, die einfach im Internet verfügbar ist.
Ich habe über Pangolin auch gleich die Möglichkeit, das noch extra abzusichern,
indem ich da Single Sign-On über Pangolin davor hänge.
Das heißt, dass es für mich transparent ist, ich bin mit meinem Pangolin-Autor authenticated.
Ich kann einfach alle meine Ressourcen direkt ansprechen und dass ich mich was
machen muss. Ich kann aber auch einfach noch ein Passwort davor hängen oder
auch einfach eine PIN, was einfach eine andere Partie von dem Mehrmöglichkeiten ist.
Oder die basteln auch noch an Mehrmöglichkeiten dafür.
Aber du kannst das Ding noch absichern. Du kannst aber auch deaktivieren die
Auth oder auf speziellen Faden nur die Auth deaktivieren.
Und dann kann ich dir einen Link schicken, eine ganz normale Domain,
die bis in mein Heimnetzwerk durchgeht, durch Talescale, witzigerweise,
in meinem Fall muss aber nicht, und auf mein Gerät zu Hause,
was in meinem Netzwerk hängt.
Und ich habe wieder Portfreigaben konfiguriert. Ich muss mich mit mit keinem
Dünndenes rumschlagen, es funktioniert einfach und es ist so wunderschön.
Da kann ich dir die nächste Folge, wenn ich sie geschnitten habe,
direkt irgendwie darüber schicken. Zum Beispiel.
Sehr nice. Das ist großartig. Die Billow und auch fast umsonst Variante davon
ist einfach deine Fritzbox benutzen.
Ja, ich habe keine Fritzbox mehr. Du hast keine Fritzbox mehr? Nee.
Ich habe das bloß, um dem noch entgegen Vorschlag entgegenzusetzen,
was ich gemacht habe, ich bin Benutzer von myfritz.net wo es einfach ein relativ
einfacher DIN-DNS-Service von AVM ist,
Und ich habe das eingerichtet für meine Fritzbox und für die Fritzbox meiner Eltern.
Und dann habe ich eingerichtet meine... Ich musste leider einstellen,
dass bei mir die IPs nicht mehr mit 1, 9, was ist das?
2 anfangen, sondern meine fangen jetzt alle mit 10, 42, 23 an. Nerd.
Und das ermöglicht mir aber, dass ich quasi einmal hin und einmal zurück ein
VPN zwischen meiner Fritzbox und der von meinen Eltern aufgemacht habe.
Was heißt das, wenn ich bei denen zu Hause bin, dann bin ich auch in meinem
eigenen Heimnetzwerk die ganze
Zeit und all die Adressen lösen auf und das funktioniert einfach super.
Und falls ihr es noch nicht wusstet, seit einer der seit etwa einem Jahr eigentlich
schon oder seit zwei Jahren, hat die Fritzbox auch WireGuard eingebaut.
Schon länger, ja, die welches Modell du hast, ja.
Aber du hast es ja damals gesagt gehabt. Und wenn du das benutzt,
kannst du dir ohne weiteres eine WireGuard-Configur stellen,
womit du auch von außen, wenn du WireGuard anmachst, in dein Heimnetzwerk reinkommst.
Weshalb ich noch nicht relativ großen Leidensdruck hatte, obwohl ich mir diesen
Pitch von dir bereits anhören durfte, auf Talescale zu wechseln.
Aber je mehr ich mir das anhöre, umso mehr denke ich mir so...
Das ermöglicht schon viel. Talescale kann noch ein bisschen mehr,
finde ich, aber das ist schon 90% von dem.
Auf jeden Fall... Sie haben auf jeden Fall ein großes Set an kreativen Ideen,
was man nicht noch als Features of Wireguard-Basis obendrauf bauen kann,
was schon ziemlich geil ist. Ja.
Ich habe halt letztens meinen Incident-Anbieter gewechselt und habe im Zuge
dessen gedacht, ich nutze einfach mal die Chance, schaffe die Fritzbox gleich mit ab.
Weil ich nicht weiß, was langfristig, also ich hätte mir einen neuen Router
eh zulegen müssen, weil ich jetzt weg von Kabel zu FDTH, also mein Glasfaseranschluss,
und da habe ich die Chance genutzt, gleich mal auf Ubiquity Hardware umzusteigen,
weil ich wollte es schon länger mal machen, ich habe auch lange überlegt,
was cool ist mit OpenWRT, aber ich hatte noch ein paar besondere Anforderungen,
wo ich sehr viel Unwissen halt hatte. Das merken wir uns mal für einer der nächsten.
Da kommen wir drauf hin. Aber wie gesagt, Deswegen gleich mit Ab von AVM weg,
weil ich auch nicht wusste, was langfristig mit AVM passiert.
Jetzt wurde ja verkauft worden.
Deswegen dachte ich mir, lustig, schau mal. Trenne dich lieber früh als später.
Ich trenne mich lieber früher als später aktuell, aber ich habe halt andere
Software, die den Teil mit erschlägt.
Aber ich meine, über MyFritz kannst du ja genau das mit erschlagen,
dass du halt in deinem Heimnetwerk von überall hinkommst, dass du dich halt
durch dein Netzwerk tunnen kannst, all dein Traffic durch dein Netzwerk schiebst.
Da müssen wir uns eigentlich, das wäre ganz witzig, Benni als Gast mit reinhauen,
weil der hat das wunderbarste,
krasseste Home-Networking-Setup, was aber auch tunnelmäßig seinen Traffic mit
Ihr könnt euch auf zukünftige Akronomie selber folgen freuen. Das machen wir.
Ob der will oder nicht, der hat uns das live zu erklären, weil das ist abgefahren.
Ja, wir machen das einfach dann bei mir und wir stellen das live bei mir dann
in der Sendung, stellen wir mein Netzwerk auf. Gut, dass wir nicht Livestream.
Jetzt sind wir mal kurz ein paar Stunden weg, bis ich wieder funktioniere.
Geplanten Downtime während des Livestreams.
Nee, aber genau. Tayscale toll, das war mein nächster Pick. Wow.
Und ein bisschen Pangolin. Pangolin war ich ja, habe ich ja erzählt.
Pangolin ist ein toller Pick. Wow.
Okay, ich glaube, an dieser Stelle haben wir es geschafft. Wir haben definitiv...
Wie, du hast keinen Pick mehr?
Achso, du meinst die... Achso, sorry. Du meinst die...
Die Folgenlänge. Habe ich noch einen Pick?
Einen kleinen hätte ich noch. Ja, Wahnsinn. okay, dann habe ich vielleicht noch einen kleinen Pick.
Ich habe mir hier so eine Liste an Sachen, die ich mir immer mal zusammenschreibe und da das Pad
für Folge 59 ein Weilchen rumlag, bevor wir die Folge tatsächlich aufgenommen
haben, haben wir hier nicht nur die Kategorie Picks alt, sondern auch noch die
Kategorie Picks sehr alt, weil wir zwischendurch haben wir gedacht,
komm, wir machen die Folge demnächst mal und dann haben wir es doch nicht gemacht.
Und hier tauchen jetzt Sachen auf, die überraschen. Kennst du das,
wenn du irgendwie ein cooles Projekt auf GitHub findest und du stellst fest,
du hast es bereits gestorben? Ja, boah. Das ist das Readme.
Oh, geil. Das kostet auch Anstar.
Genau. Und hier gucke ich in mein eigenes Pad rein und denke mir so,
was sind das für Begriffe? Die kenne ich nicht.
Aber ich habe die irgendwann mal hier reingestellt, um die als Pick im Podcast zu erwähnen.
Und jetzt muss ich mir das selber nochmal angucken. Ein Tool,
was wirklich ein sehr kleines, aber nices Tool ist, wo ich aber noch nicht wirklich
einen Zweck hatte, es zu verwenden.
Aber wenn ich es mal brauche, dann bin ich froh, dass es das gibt. Das heißt Rage.
Rage ist eine Implementierung von Age Encryption und Age Encryption ist einfach nur eine,
Ich dachte erst mal eine andere Richtung im Zahn der Zeit entlang,
weil wir ja sehr viel über Age Verification gerade in der Welt philosophieren.
Age is a modern file Encryption format for multiple pluggable recipients.
Ich packe es in die Show Notes, es ist bereits drin und es gibt ein Command-Line-Tool
dafür, das heißt Rage und damit kann man Dateien verschlüsseln für andere Leute.
Und jetzt ist natürlich diese Sache mit Public-Private-Key Infrastructure.
Ich weiß nicht, benutze noch Keybase? Benutze noch GPG?
Hin und wieder tatsächlich, aber selten. Wüsstest du, wie du an meinen Key rankommst,
wenn du mir eine verschlüsselte Datei schicken möchtest?
Naja, ich würde auf einen Public-Key-Server schauen und hoffen,
dass dann alles nicht expires.
Bist du sicher, dass ich da einen habe? Nö, überhaupt nicht.
Weißt du, was ein cooler Public-Key-Server ist, wo jeder einen Public-Key gehostet
hat? Du meinst GitHub? Ja.
Und Rage Du gehst auf github.com slash hoodie und dann nicht auf meinen Ordner,
auf Slash, sondern auf Punkt Keys.
Und da stehen SSH Keys von mir, Public Keys.
Damit kannst du mir zum Beispiel die Möglichkeit geben, wenn du die in deine
Authorized Keys pastelt, mich auf deinen SSH-Server einzuloggen.
Cool, du hast vier SSH-E255-Keys, ich auch. Du kannst auch auf github.com slash
hoodie.png gehen, dann siehst du meinen Avatar.
Geht bei jedem GitHub-Account. So, und Rage ist ein.
Asymmetrisches Verschlüsselungstool, was SSH-Keys zum Verschlüsseln nehmen kann. Das ist cool.
Das heißt, du kannst mit meinem Public SSH-Keys Dateien verschlüsseln mir schicken
und nur ich kann sie entschlüsseln. Kann das gleichzeitig mit...
Also ich sehe erstmal bei dir vier Keys. Du kannst es für mehrere Recipients.
Sehr gut, weil ich wusste ja nicht, welchen Key ich nutze und habe auf jedem
Device einen anderen von denen und auf,
Du könntest für jeden Teilnehmer einer Org oder sowas.
Ja, aber ich könnte ja an dich einfach mit all diesen Keys schlüsseln,
da kannst du es machen. Und falls einer davon geleakt ist, kommen die Leute da dran.
Top. Also dann hoffe ich, dass du geleakt die Keys auch, dann löscht das dein Profil.
Aber ja, klar, an der Stelle ist es auch praktisch. Noch ein Grund mehr,
seine GitHub SSH-Keys immer mal wieder anzuschauen, ob man die noch braucht
und ob die noch Joyce barken oder ob man die vielleicht löschen kann. Ob die Joyce barken.
Sehr schön. Das war mein Pick Rage und ich glaube, jetzt kann ich den sechs
Sendungen lang durchs Pad geschoben habe, endlich mal löschen. Geil.
Genau. Du hast noch einen kleinen. Einen kleinen habe ich noch und zwar ist
das ein GitHub-Repo, das schon eine Weile alt ist. Letzter Commitment von vor fünf Jahren.
Ich habe es vor kurzem erst entdeckt. Es ist viel zu praktisch.
Es ist ein Bookmarklet. Eins.
Nutzt man ja irgendwie gefühlt nicht mehr so häufig. Früher hatte ich irgendwie
so ein Array an Sachen, die man häufiger genutzt hat. Ich schreibe mir regelmäßig
selber nochmal welche. Krass.
Kennst du Leute, die in Meetings vor dem Laptop in der Webcam auf so Laufbändern laufen?
Haben wir bei uns nicht, aber ja. Als Konzept ja.
Es ist unwahrscheinlich nervig, wenn die Leute die ganze Zeit so hin und her
wackeln, weil sie gerade auf einem Laufband laufen.
Ich habe mir ein Bookmarklet gebaut, wo ich dann...
Bookmarklets kannst du ja eigentlich in die Kommandozeile, also in die Adressleiste
vom Browser einfach eingeben.
Und meins heißt Hide Somebody, dann gibt sie den Namen von der Person ein und dann wird das Video...
Dann geht ein Prompt auf, was in JavaScript primitiv ist,
ein Prompt, wo du Text entgeben kannst, das ist eine Funktion,
der Rückgabewert ist der String, den du eingegeben hast und dann sucht die CSS-Identifier,
wo die Person drin steht und löscht die aus dem DOM.
Nice, geil. Und ich meine, es ist ja nur für dich und es ist ja nur der Feed,
der Video-Feed vermutlich, nicht der Audio-Feed. Genau.
Geil, das ist praktisch. Was ist dein Bookmarklet? Es heißt Kill Sticky.
Erzähl. Ist anscheinend sehr populär, obwohl es hat nur 800 Stars.
Ist ein Bookmarklet, wie hier steht, to remove sticky elements and restore scrolling to webpages.
Und es ist viel zu praktisch, weil es einfach jegliche Sticky Banner oder Pop-Overs
oder Models einfach wegkillt.
Es macht einfach sowas weg wie Cookie Banner, es macht aber auch einfach sowas
weg wie blöde UI, die hochscrollt, wenn du so runterscrollst,
dann gehst du die Tab-Leisten wieder auf.
Wenn du wieder hochscrollst oder sowas, auf Mobile finde ich es sehr schlimm ist.
Machst einfach das, ist weg. Ist geil. Gehen Bookmarklets auf Mobile-Browsern? Ja.
Kannst du das Bookmark speichern, öffnest das für das JavaScript aus.
Das ist super praktisch. Nice.
Killsticky. Müsst du mal ausprobieren. Das ist nice. Einfach nice.
Ich finde es witzig, dass da... Wenn das irgendwie nicht mehr Mainstage ist
und du da noch irgendwas dran machen musst, kannst du es ja forken und kill Jens Sticky.
Gut, dann haben wir ganz schnell noch rumschaut. Wir haben über Browser geredet,
wir haben über AI geredet, wir haben über Editoren geredet, wir haben über VPNs
geredet, wir haben über Verschlüsselung geredet, wir haben über Wow.
Wow. Das ist eine typische Akkultusüberfolge. Wir haben noch nicht über Programmiersprachen
geredet. Ja, die stimmt.
Nächstes Mal. Oder übernächstes Mal. Der allerletzte Pick.
Der allerletzte Pick. Nur weil es hier noch steht. von vor einem Jahr noch,
weil ich gezwungenerweise auf Arbeit Go schreiben musste.
Und es ist glücklicherweise vorbei.
Habe ich vor Verzweiflung tatsächlich gegoogelt, gibt es eigentlich Compile-to-Go-Sprachen?
Ich brauche eine Abstraktionsebene, um mich von den Schmerzen zu sparen.
Und die, die ich gefunden habe, die tatsächlich eine Zeit lang tot aussah,
aber tatsächlich die haben einen schicken Online-Editor.
Die heißen Borgo Language. Und das ist eine Sprache, die gewollt sehr wie Rust
aussieht und nach Go kompiliert.
Das ist doch 100% von Leuten wie dir, die Schmerz hatten, fuck,
ich muss Go machen. Aber ich würde lieber Rust machen.
Go ist in vielen Belangen als Runtime nicht schlecht, nur die Sprache ist scheiße.
Aber lass uns dieses Thema nicht allzu sehr vertiefen, falls wir mal einen schönen...
Haben wir schon in der Vergangenheit.
Ich könnte auch... Ich habe jetzt übrigens unser Transcript-Verzeichnis hier
in Z aufgemacht und kann jetzt mal nach Bogo... Multibuffersuche!
Golang. Genau. So, jetzt habe ich hier Multibuffers und ich kann die mit einem
Shortcut einmal alle zufalten.
Und es kam vor in Folge 0.9 in 24, 34 ähm...
Ist halt die Frage, wie häufig wir wirklich Golang gesagt haben und vor allen
Dingen, wie häufig, und nicht nur Go und wie häufig von der Transkription auch,
als auch hier erkannt wurde. das ist halt immer ein bisschen blöder alles.
Vielleicht können wir das nochmal irgendwie, also ich weiß nicht,
die Daten sind wohl bereinigt, aber Transkripte werden ja auch besser und vielleicht
können wir das irgendwann mal ein bisschen besser machen. Vielleicht gibt es
ja auch schon ein Tool von jemand anders.
Letztes Tidbit, ich kann übrigens voraussagen, was JTGPT denkt.
Was du gesagt hast, give me a random number between 1 and 50.
Ich habe noch nicht auf Enter gedrückt. Ne. Was denkst du, was er sagt?
Ich tippe auf 23. 37. Ich drücke auf Enter.
37.
Das ist die zufälligste Zufallzahl. Es war bis vor kurzem noch wiederholbar 27.
Seit letzter Woche produziert ChatGPT auf diese Frage die Antwort 37.
Aber es gibt ein Veritasium-Video, warum 37 die randomste Zahl ist.
Die zufälligste Zufallzahl.
Ich glaube, wir haben eine sehr lange Folge produziert und definitiv die 100-Stunden-Marke
mit akronomisierbar geknackt.
Das heißt, wenn ihr uns bis hierhin gehört habt und alle bisherigen Folgen gehört
habt, dann habt ihr über 100 Stunden unser Geschwafel im Kopf.
Wenn ihr so seid wie ich, jetzt gibt es eine neue Folge, jetzt gibt es neue
Folgen Star Trek Strange New Worlds.
Als die zweite Staffel Game of Thrones rauskam, habe ich die erste Staffel nochmal
geguckt. Als die dritte Staffel rauskam, habe ich die erste und die zweite Staffel nochmal geguckt.
Ich bin gerade bei der Hälfte von Staffel 2 von Strange New Worlds,
weil Staffel 3 jetzt rausgekommen ist.
Wenn unsere Zuhörer so sind wie wir, dann sehen sie, oh nein,
es gibt eine Folge akronymisierbar. Wir müssen jetzt 100 Stunden akronymisierbar hören.
Ja, wenn da auch nur ein Mensch draußen so drauf ist, das wäre insane.
Also hoffentlich nicht, aber ich kann mir nicht vorstellen. Tut es nicht.
Bitte, tut euch das nicht an.
In dem Sinne, ich glaube, wir machen Schluss für heute. Auf jeden Fall.
Es war mir eine große Freude. Es war großartig, mal wieder eine Folge aufzunehmen. Folge 26.
Folge 26. habt noch ein schönes Internet und hört weiter fleißig andere Podcasts
ich glaube in eurem Podcatcher kommt gleich der nächste in 3 2 1.